mes chers collègues on va attaquer cette
cette audition cette nouvelle audition
du ministre ravi de vous retrouver après
cette nos deux auditions ce matin
consacrées à
l'écoute des représentants de des pays
scandinaves nordiques et des pays
également de l'Europe de l'Est sur leur
modèle de d'armée en tout cas monsieur
le ministre merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour parler d'une actualité
importante celui de l'aide militaire de
la France à l'Ukraine et sur ce sujet je
sais que mes chers collègues vous seriez
ravis de le questionnaire de ministre
sur d'autres sujets mais je vous propose
de nous concentrer on va dire ce sujet
d'importance d'autant plus qu'il fait
l'objet d'une couverture médiatique
forte et donc qui est nécessaire de ne
pas laisser libre cours à de nombreuses
comptes vérités que nous avons pu lire
dans dans la presse et c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi la la Commission a lancé une
mission d'information pour mieux évaluer
ce soutien militaire à l'Ukraine dont
les rapporteurs seront le nés le royaume
Pérou et Christophe nigelin et
finalement aujourd'hui nous allons
ouvrir le mouvement de manière
collective sur ce sujet là mais vous
aurez à coeur chers collègues de
dépasser et nous rendre les conclusions
de votre mission puisque bien entendu
deux heures ne seront pas ne suffisantes
que vous le savez nous revenons de d'un
déplacement dans les pays baltes avec
plusieurs collègues j'ai envie de
sérieux Fabien aîné Pierrick Berthelot
et c'est peu dire que ces états
regardent à la lettre l'aide à portée
par chaque pays à l'Ukraine et nous
sommes conscients qui existent parfois
une forme de rivalité médiatique qui a
pu s'installer entre différents pays qui
conduisent parfois certains à céder à
des effets d'annonces sans que les
promesses soient toujours suivies des
faits notre pays a choisi pour sa part
dans un premier temps une relative
discrétion ce qui a donné lieu parfois à
des batailles de chiffres mais aussi à
certaines critiques et pourtant notre
pays on le sait joue un rôle extrêmement
important dans cette aide ne serait-ce
qu'au travers de l'exemple de la session
d'amixrc qui a conduit d'autres pays à
livrer des Charlots de conception
occidentales et l'Ukraine à plusieurs
reprises marquées sa reconnaissance
envers l'action de la France et encore
récemment le ministre de la Défense
ukrainienne nous a témoigné de ce bien
là il y a insisté sur la fiabilité la
pertinence de l'aide française qu'elle
soit d'ailleurs de nature matérielle ou
immatériel voilà maintenant plus d'un an
que la guerre en Ukraine a éclaté et
encore aujourd'hui aucune perspective de
règlement passifs de ce qu'on finit je
voudrais donc vous poser trois questions
tout d'abord pouvez-vous nous faire
monsieur le ministre un bilan global de
l'aide militaire que nous avons apporté
à l'Ukraine il serait aussi utile que
vous puissiez nous préciser la façon de
cette aide s'organise et complémentaire
avec celle de l'Union européenne qui
concerne aussi bien la formation que des
sessions d'équipements par exemple dans
ce cas des précisions sur les mécanismes
financiers mis en oeuvre par l'Union
européenne serait les bienvenus
notamment sur la facilité européenne de
paix nos contributions et des
remboursements dont nous avons pu
bénéficier voilà pour la première
question et la deuxième question serait
finalement l'impact de cette aide
militaire française à la fois pour les
Ukrainiens sur le terrain mais également
pour nos armées car nous savons cette
aide n'a pu s'effectuer au dans un
premier temps que par le prélèvement sur
leur stock et matériel en service et
puis on pourrait également s'interroger
ces conflits venaient à perdurer
jusqu'où sommes-nous prêts à aller dans
cette tête monsieur le ministre pour
répondre à sa question sans plus
attendre je vous souhaite la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés de vous retrouver
pour pour cette séance de de contrôle
qui me semble d'ailleurs la bienvenue
parce que
l'endurance avec lequel nous devons
évidemment envisager ce qui se passe en
Ukraine nécessite aussi beaucoup de
transparence autant que faire ce peu
avec la part de discrétion qui va avec
le secret des opérations évidemment mais
enfin je pense que c'est cette ce moment
dans lequel il m'est donné de répondre à
vos questions et de rendre compte alors
présentation nationale de ce qui est
fait à mon avis participe aussi à la
fiabilité à la solidité de la de la
position de la France et de la manière
dont on s'inscrit et dans cette affaire
là et dans lequel le président de la
République a souhaité que nous agissions
je vais pas être très long si vous en
êtes d'accord monsieur le le président
est peut-être peut-être tout de suite à
un peu à vos questions ce qui permet
peut-être de laisser de la place aux
échanges les plus interactifs je crois
qu'il y en a pas mal c'est pour ça que
je préfère le faire comme cela puis on a
des jeux l'occasion de parler de la LPM
enfin janvier évidemment très vite je
vais revenir devant vous pour parler le
programmation militaire donc là
peut-être pour rentrer dans le détail
sur l'aide à l'Ukraine déjà rappeler les
principes parce que parfois il y a des
choses assez étonnantes qu'on peut lire
ici ou là dans la presse ou parmi
certains commentateurs il est évident
que c'est une aide de légitime défense
bon il faut redémarrer par là et que une
aide de légitime défense ça veut dire
que nous aidons militairement un pays
agressé ce qui n'est pas la même chose
que d'aider un pays agresseur
et que par définition nous sommes là
pour que l'Ukraine puisse se retrouver
la plénitude à sa souveraineté et de ses
frontières en tout cas dans les critères
que les Ukrainiens vaudront bien définir
je le redis aussi puisque si on veut que
notre propre souveraineté soit respectée
il faut évidemment aussi faire respecter
celle des autres et aider à faire
respecter celle des autres ce n'est pas
à géométrie variable
cette aide à la légitime défense elle
est clairement aussi
identifiée enfin elle ne correspond pas
à ce que certains appelleraient le
risque de cobelligence voilà aussi que
il faut reclarifier les choses si besoin
en est et donc je redis ces principes ce
sont les mêmes depuis un an mais
évidemment il compte beaucoup la
deuxième des choses c'est évidemment que
cette aide militaire ne vienne pas
abîmer notre propre appareil de défense
alors ça peut venir le modifier un temps
je reviendrai après sur les conditions
de la soutenabilité au fond c'est aussi
un peu la question que je présente vous
m'avez posé mais
la soutenabilité
sont deux registres complètement
différents là aussi j'aurais l'occasion
de répondre à vos questions je ne vais
pas plus avant sur ce point mais c'est
un évidemment une rouge que nous sommes
fixée depuis le début et forte
heureusement notre pays pour plein de
raisons et des capacités quand même à le
faire puis la troisième des choses ça
répond aussi à votre interpellation en
tout cas où questionnement sur les
fameux classement où il y a eu une
petite mode médiatique autour de cette
affaire là
considérons que l'honneur de la France
c'est de faire
utile et d'être fiable et que moi
j'étais frappé dans certaines
ministériels de l'OTAN de l'Union
européenne du format Rammstein d'avoir
parfois des homologues je donnerais
évidemment pas les pays mais dans lequel
certains hommes blocs commencèrent à
regarder l'efficacité de leur aide
militaire au poids aux tonnage j'étais
assez stupéfiant donc je pense que
effectivement notre manière de faire
depuis le début c'est de quel est au
plus près des besoins en défense du
partenaire ukrainien et la LI ukrainien
et aussi je l'ai souvent dit d'être
fiable parce que c'est l'honneur de la
France que de promettre ce qui est livré
et de livrer ce qui est vraiment promis
et puisque là aussi parfois des
décalages ont pu se faire jour pas une
critique c'est un fait et donc au fond
de tous les classements du monde cette
fiabilité dans le présence Hélène ski a
pu lui-même m'en parler quand je faisais
la caisse ou lorsque je l'ai accueilli à
Orly lorsque évidemment je discute
régulièrement avec avec mon homologue
cette fiabilité fait au fond notre
marque de fabrique et je pense que c'est
clé pour aujourd'hui comme pour comme
pour demain ensuite monsieur le
Président il y a des segments sur
lesquels nous sommes attendus ça me
permet à la fois de faire le bilan mais
aussi au fond de parler un peu de
l'actualité et de dresser quelques
perspectives la première des choses et
c'est strictement défensif en tout point
c'est évidemment la défense solaire et
pour cause parce que l'agression russe
elle se fait beaucoup par les airs
autant sur des cibles militaires le
champ de bataille
que des cibles civiles et ça a été
évidemment la grande actualité
malheureusement de tout l'hiver des
infrastructures plutôt énergétiques
plutôt dans des grands centres urbains
qui est essentiellement et donc
évidemment le solaire dit multicouche
différentes strates potentielles est un
des besoins sur lesquels l'Ukraine nous
attend massivement alors c'est vrai
parce qu'on a démarré avec les mistrales
c'est vrai dans la zone intermédiaire
avec les crottes et c'est évidemment
encore plus vrai demain avec le santeng
ou pour les Américains le patriote je
crois que là pour le coup la défense
solaire et le est évidemment un enjeu
clé parce que c'est là où il y a des
vies humaines dans une dimension c'est
plus humaniste pardon mais c'est là
aussi il y a des villes humaines et des
vies civiles à préserver le deuxième
segment sur lequel nous sommes attendus
ce sont évidemment les équipements
terrestres équipements terrestres qui
permettent de mener des
contre-offensives qui permettent de
fixer la ligne de front qui permettent
le cas échéant de reprendre des
positions comme nous l'avons vu à
l'automne et qui permettent aussi au
fond aujourd'hui d'avoir une situation
sur le sur le terrain que vous pouvez
voir comme étant relativement équilibré
en les Russes sont à la manœuvre mais
enfin à l'initiative enfin on voit bien
quand même qu'on est sur des lignes de
front qui qui varient mais qui ne varie
pas de manière spectaculaire je pense
que c'est comme ça qu'on peut résumer
les choses donc ces équipements
terrestres c'est vrai de l'artillerie
sur lequel nous sommes enfin la France a
des références et une solidité c'est
vrai pour les vieux dispositifs les
fameux TF1 tractées c'est vrai pour les
dispositifs désormais bien connus de
canon César avec 18 18 canons qui
avaient été livrés pratiquement dans les
premières semaines les premiers mois en
tout cas du conflit des nouveaux canons
12 qui ont été achetés par le Fonds de
soutien je reviendrai sur le fond dans
un instant c'est vrai des frappes en
profondeur
avec les rues
l'entreprise militaire au fond
d'ailleurs assez curieusement n'a pas
été très médiatisé alors que pourtant
nous l'avons annoncé et ça a été pour
moi une grande stupéfaction de voir ce
débat sur les chars émergés au mois de
janvier en disant arme lourdes pas ma
part lourde ce qui a stupéfait tous les
artilleurs ou en tout cas tous nos
soldats de l'armée de terre parce que un
canon César ou une pièce de lle c'est
une arme lourde donc c'est là aussi on a
une approche trop médiatique aussi de ce
que ce qui était les armements et au
fond c'est la doctrine d'emploi c'est ce
qu'on en fait aussi qui fait que c'est
défensif ou évidemment offensif c'est
vrai évidemment des TF1 j'en ai parlé
des amx-10rc vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président qui sont des chars qui
viennent d'arriver en Ukraine ça répond
aussi à des questions qui me sont
peut-être posées
des transports également de troupes et
VAB enfin bref un certain nombre de
d'équipements sur lequel nous étions
attendus après il y a ce qui va autour
c'est une autre particularité française
depuis le début
c'est que livrer un système ou une arme
c'est une chose livrer tout ce qui va
avec autour en est une autre le MCO les
pièces détachées les munitions qui vont
avec les carburants et donc au fond à
chaque fois nous avons nous avons essayé
de dégager un kit au fond de se dire bah
voilà non seulement on donne un système
mais on donne pour l'équivalent de 3 4 5
mois d'usage et de vite ce système dans
notre popularité chez les ukrainiens et
dans la fameuse fiabilité dont je vous
parlais c'était un élément clé parce que
livrer une carcasse de ferraille pardon
qui fonctionne quelques jours n'a pas
d'intérêt et j'aimerais parce que le MCO
évidemment et l'éléphant qui est dans la
pièce et qui va s'inviter énormément
dans les dans les temps qui vont venir
donc ça évidemment c'est un point clé le
carburant dont on parle trop peu mais
qui est évidemment très important
l'enjeu maintenant est en terminerai par
là évidemment c'est la soutenabilité de
cette affaire sur le moyen long terme on
voit bien que les choses peuvent durer
je ne souhaite pas bon en tout cas on
doit se préparer à ça et ça veut donc
dire qu'il faut qu'on prenne un certain
nombre de dispositions ou qu'on continue
de persévérer dans des dispositions que
nous avons pu prendre un déjà à chaque
fois que l'on peut privilégier de
l'achat direct des Ukrainiens vers nos
industriels plutôt que le prélèvement
dans nos armées faut le faire c'est le
sens du fond de soutien je m'en étais
pas caché aussi auprès de vous la
dernière fois qui a aussi
une vertu pardon de ce mot parce qu'il
est décalé en période de guerre et qui
oblige aussi nos industriels à
travailler avec un partenaire allié en
guerre donc aussi oblige à raccourcir
les délais de livraison éventuellement
aussi des délais de prise de commande
sur le terrain évidemment de juridique
ou financier donc ça c'est évidemment
important lorsqu'on a des prélèvements
être capable de recompléter le plus vite
possible ces fameux dispositif
économiques de guerre là aussi je crois
que vous avez des questions à me poser
sur le sujet donc je me réserve pour
dans un instant mais je fais du César le
le évidemment
l'exemple un peu de ce que je souhaite
désormais pouvoir faire sur d'autres sur
d'autres équipements au fond on a donné
des Césars on a prélevé 18 César dans
les stocks de l'armée française dès les
premières semaines et je dis du conflit
bon bah là je peux vous annoncer que une
trentaine de césares ont été livrés
entre le mois de novembre de cette année
et le mois de mars de l'année 2024 on
était sur un délai pratiquement de 44
mois pour produire un César les délais
vont tomber à 18 on commence à être dans
quelque chose qui devient
significativement différent et qui donc
nous permet aussi de regarder évidemment
les sessions à venir un peu différemment
parce que dès lors qu'industrie commence
à produire évidemment c'est clé la
soutenabilité j'en ai commencé en parler
c'est évidemment le MCO
il y a forcément une attrition la triche
on combat est une chose
la trission par l'usure la tricion
naturelle d'un équipement n'est une
autre et là il est clair qu'on doit
pouvoir faire mieux formation sur le MCO
beaucoup de choses sont faites en lien
avec nos partenaires et amis polonais
formation ou évidemment à distance aussi
bon là je répondrai aussi à vos
questions en tout cas c'est un enjeu sur
lequel la France souhaite être aux
avant-postes formation j'en ai aussi un
tout petit peu parlé on a aussi
plusieurs types de formation sur lequel
nous avons effectivement déplié
tranquillement notre offre de formation
pour correspondre à des besoins que
d'autres partenaires européens ou
occidentaux ne mettaient pas en œuvre
donc c'est aussi pour ça que parfois
votre interpellation mais pourquoi on
est on a pu apparaître comme étant un
peu en décalé tout simplement parce
qu'on a aussi pris des segments qui
étaient rares voilà par définition sur
des unités plus petites sur parfois un
nombre de soldats plus réduit mais ça
aussi on l'assume parce que c'est ce que
demander les Ukrainiens donc nous
l'avons tout simplement fait et enfin
l'économie de guerre est évidemment une
des conditions aussi de la soutenabilité
à long terme font enfin faciliter
européenne de paix puisque vous m'avez
posé la question ça aussi c'est un enjeu
majeur j'étais assez étonné au début que
les fameux classement dont vous avez
fait référence ne traduisent pas la
facilité européenne de paix c'est un
absolument invraisemblable ça veut dire
au fond que seul l'aide bilatérale était
comptabilisée mais tout ce qu'on faisait
de manière mutualisée en multilatérale
ne rentrait pas en ligne de compte c'est
à dire que d'autres pays donnaient des
armes au fond payer par la France
le remboursement et ça comptait pas
comme aide à l'Ukraine ça aussi c'était
absurde donc je suis heureux que ces
différents instituts et plus corrigés ce
biais méthodologique majeur et donc la
facilité européenne de paix fait l'objet
évidemment de contribution importante de
la France pratiquement un milliard
d'euros qui est une facilité dont je
vous rappelle qu'elle doit aussi pouvoir
servir à nos partenaires africains parce
que c'est pour cela qu'elle avait été
créé initialement mais tout le monde
comprend très bien que ce soit
l'instrument le plus efficace le plus
réactif en ce moment pour aider pour
aider l'Ukraine voilà de manière
synthétique monsieur le Président
évidemment je me tiens à la disposition
de tous les commissaires pour apprendre
à vos questions merci monsieur le
ministre d'avoir brossé en si peu de
temps une une un retour aussi global de
l'aide militaire française à l'Ukraine
je vois qu'il y a déjà de nombreuses
questions et je vous propose de
continuer dans la démarche que nous
avions inauguré lors de votre dernier
audition avec une autre forme
d'interactivité avec les orateurs de
groupe mais en demandant aux orateurs de
groupe si possible de se limiter à une
intervention de 2 minutes puisque je
vois qu'il y a énormément de questions
pour le groupe Renaissance la parole est
à Lionel Royer Perrot
monsieur le ministre au nom de
l'ensemble des commissaires du groupe
Renaissance je vous remercie pour votre
présence cet après-midi devant nous
c'est déjà la quatrième fois que vous ne
vous auditionnons depuis le début de la
législature et donc je tiens à souligner
votre grande disponibilité à venir
répondre au commissaire de la Défense
nationale et des forces armées un an
après le début de la guerre en Ukraine
l'aide internationale à la légitime
défense comme venait de le dire à
l'instant et largement disséqué tel pays
se montrerait particulièrement généreux
l'aide états-unienne première armée du
monde s'élèverait à plus de 44 milliards
de dollars tel autre a contrario ne
ferait preuve que d'un faible
volontarisme c'est ce qui est Monsieur
le Ministre et vous le savez bien
régulièrement reproché vous venez
d'ailleurs de le dire par les médias et
certains sites tank à notre pays le
classement faisant aujourd'hui
celui de l'Institut économique de quelle
place notre pays au 9e rang des
principaux donateurs d'aide militaires à
l'Ukraine avec un total de 700 millions
d'euros je voudrais prendre ici pourtant
le contre-pied de cette affirmation qui
me semble manquer c'est loin qu'on
puisse dire de nuances notre soutien
militaire se mesure davantage par la
qualité du matériel fourni que par sa
quantité mentionnons et vous l'avez dit
à ce titre la livraison de 18 canons au
César de 15 canons tractés TF1 de 115 mm
prélevé par urgence sur nos propres
stocks nous savons de plus que l'aide de
la France passe très largement par une
dimension multilatérale notamment dans
le cadre européen de la facilité
européenne pour la paix que vous avez
signalé à cet instant et par le fort
soutien de l'OTAN en termes
d'équipements et de formation enfin ce
classement fait la part belle aux effets
d'annonce et j'ai le défaut de croire
que notre pays mais là aussi vous l'avez
dit offre ce qu'il promet ce qui n'est
pas une qualité unanimement répandue et
me semble-t-il il faut le préciser en
somme monsieur le ministre comment
pouvons-nous infléchir la rhétorique
ambiante faisant de notre pays un allié
soi-disant de ce contrôle du courage
ukrainien je note d'ailleurs que la
question de l'influence informationnelle
est aujourd'hui capitale et aimait le
souhait que notre futur loi de
programmation militaire en cours de
finalisation satell également à
renforcer nos possibilités en la matière
le soutien militaire à un pays en guerre
n'est pas une action anodine nous le
savons et nous mesurons ici pleinement
ce que cela sous-tend en termes
symbolique et capacitaire les millions
et les canons ont des conséquences
concrètes sur le champ de bataille
suivant les appartenances doctrinales il
est tout à fait légitime ou politique de
trouver le soutien apporté qu'il soit
timoré calibré ou pour certains
insuffisants sans vouloir déclencher de
polémique inutile et inopportune
j'aimerais monsieur le ministre vous
interroger sur la chaîne de décision
politique au administrative de telle
livraison et notamment sur la place que
le Parlement pourrait jouer en ce
domaine et je termine les réponses que
vous pourrez nous apporter serviront à
nourrir la réflexion de la mission
d'information flash consacrée donc au
soutien militaire à l'Ukraine dans J'ai
l'honneur d'assurer donc la direction
avec mon collègue Christophe nigellen je
vous en remercie effectivement merci
pour cette question j'avais fait
transmettre l'information aux
coordinateur de groupe de s'imiter à
deux minutes et on a un peu dépassé il
va mettre difficile maintenant de
demander aux autres groupes de respecter
un temps de minutes mais je sais que le
ministre à toutes les capacités pour
être très synthétique et à chaque fois
je viens c'est plus en plus difficile
non
efficace sur les classements je pense
qu'on s'est déjà dit un certain nombre
de choses moi je pense que
la guerre est une chose grave et que
j'ai parfois du mal avec ces rhétoriques
trop trop médiatique de classement tous
les 15 jours enfin je veux dire
ce que Winston Churchill a eu son
classement pour savoir s'il est déçu
suffisamment bien la France libre du
général de Gaulle en d'autres temps
enfin pardon de comparaison n'est pas
raison mais je trouve que la gravité de
la situation demande un peu de cas moi
ce que je vois c'est quand le présente
ski quitte son pays il va à Washington
pour des raisons qu'on comprend bien il
va à Londres et il dit à Paris avec le
président de la République et le
chancelier scholls mais des choses qui
sont qui montrent bien le rôle de la
France dans cette affaire et on verra
évidemment je crois l'histoire dira
aussi des choses et je pense qu'il faut
effectivement être fiable et sérieux et
que ça pour le coup ça n'a pas de prix
chaîne de décision bon Mono est très
respectueux des institutions en la
matière il va sans dire que le Président
de la République comme je faisais armées
avalises politiquesment évidemment
l'ensemble des décisions de cession moi
je les fais préparer systématiquement
par l'état-major des armées parce que
comme je vous ai dit une dining rouge
c'est de ne pas abîmer notre appareil de
défense c'est donc aussi les armées et
l'envie aux armées évidemment de faire
un premier avis ensuite je demande un
avis à la Délégation Générale pour
l'Armement la capacité pour l'industriel
de gaz d'échéance concernés à
recompléter rapidement c'est souvent ces
deux critères qui permettent de
commencer à avoir un chemin de décision
qu'on est capable de faire à mon niveau
il y a évidemment l'échange avec le
partenaire ukrainien quand je dis mon
niveau mon équipe ou moi-même parce
qu'une fois de plus il faut que ça
corresponde aussi à des réalités de
besoins
identifier exprimés sur sur le terrain
en lien avec la mission de défense
évidemment présente à Kiev en lien avec
la mission de défense ukrainienne
présente à Paris là il y a un canal qui
est très performant et qui fonctionne
très très bien depuis le début
évidemment du du conflit juridiquement
l'acte de section c'est le ministre qui
le signe comme pour n'importe quelle
session d'ailleurs de n'importe quel
matériel dans quelques conditions que ce
soit dans les armées et puis évidemment
c'est moi qui vous rencontre comme je le
fais en ce moment même parfois c'est
vous puisque le fond de soutien
typiquement est une décision du
Parlement en tant que tel que vous avez
vous-même voté en projet de loi de
finance rectificatif et puis comme nous
sommes dans une la programmation
militaire par définition évidemment il y
a un tableau quand même qui fixe
l'ensemble des éléments et je dépasse
juste de 5 secondes de plus pour dire et
vous confirmez à la représentation
nationale monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés que précisément
l'aide et le soutien à l'Ukraine sortira
de la loi de programmation militaire
version nous considérons que là
programmation militaire c'est pour le
format des armées de nos armées parce
que c'est pour donner quelque chose
transparence vis-à-vis du Parlement et
qui donne aussi un cadre plus réel
d'exécution dans un nombre de programmes
d'investissement et que donc l'aide à
l'Ukraine rebasculera en annualité
budgétaire sur lequel on entend le
parlementaire vous aurez donc à vous
vous exprimer et à voter et puis je
rajouterai aussi que dans le cadre des
commissions de contrôle et en tout cas
d'explications des licences
d'exportation d'armes et bah en 2023 au
mois de juillet je crois prochain avec
les ministres de Bercy et les ministres
de du Quai d'Orsay j'aurais vous rendre
compte des différentes licences
d'exportation qui auront été prises pour
l'Ukraine
merci Monsieur ministre pour cette
annonce importante également de la non
finalement sur le fait que cette aide
militaire ne rentre pas dans la LPM pour
le groupe rassemblement national la
parole est à Caroline Colombier
je vais essayer de respecter le temps au
nom du groupe rassemble national je vous
remercie également de votre présence et
de vous explications très très clair et
direct depuis le début du conflit
l'Ukraine et la Russie subissent des
pertes matérielles et humaines
extrêmement élevées selon le site de
renseignements sources ouvertes oryx la
Russie a perdu plus de 9628 véhicules
tandis que l'Ukraine on a perdu environ
3077 parmi ces véhicules de nombreux
chars d'assaut modernes des pièces
d'artillerie des radars des avions de
chasse et même un croiseur ces chiffres
sont d'autant plus impressionnants
qu'ils sont tronqués seuls les pertes
confirmées et figurent ils ne prennent
pas en compte non plus la consommation
de munitions qui dépasserait les
capacités de production de tous les pays
de l'OTAN réunis États-Unis inclus du
côté des pertes humaines les estimations
américaines donnent un bilan global
approximatif de 200 000 blessés et tués
au combat
inutile d'en faire un tabou si nous
venions à subir un de cette ampleur nos
armées pourtant les meilleurs d'Europe
n'auraient pas les capacités de tenir
dans le temps ce qui nous amène au sujet
de la future loi de programmation
militaire jamais depuis la guerre froide
nous n'avions autant eu besoin d'une
armée forte aux capacités décuplées il
faut sortir des logiques
échantillonnaires et nous donner les
moyens de défendre la France non plus
seulement dans le cadre d'une coalition
mais de manière indépendante face à des
pays comme la Russie et la Chine qui
risquerait un conflit pour aider la
France à défendre qui
risquerait pardon un conflit pour aider
la France à défendre la
Nouvelle-Calédonie ou risquerait un
conflit pour défendre nos intérêts en
Afrique dans le cadre de l'OTAN quelle
est la force de notre voix par rapport à
celle des Américains la politique s'est
prévoir et prévoir c'est aussi prévoir
le pire malheureusement aussi
pouvez-vous nous garantir que la future
LPM prendra en considération le rétexte
ukrainien notamment sur la question de
l'attrition des troupes et des matériels
je vous remercie
monsieur le Président bon je pense que
si on veut être rigoureux on ne peut pas
se comparer à l'Ukraine non mais je le
dis ici à dessin à la Commission de la
Défense nationale et forces armées de la
République française
on est une puissance dotée on est une
puissance membre de l'OTAN la
sensibilité politique que vous
représentez conteste cette alliance
militaire c'est votre droit le plus
strict mais enfin au moment où nous
parlons peut-être je vous le député
génétique qui remue
si c'est plus nuancé vous me
l'expliquerez mais comme le député la
chaux n'est pas là je me je me tourne de
l'autre côté
c'est très juste je dois l'avouer en
tout cas il est clair que l'appartenance
à l'OTAN change la chose le fait pardon
des mois mais d'être à l'ouest de notre
plateau continental européen et non pas
à l'Est change les choses bon donc je
pense que on ne peut pas comparer nos
modèles d'armée et d'ailleurs si on
devait se comparer avec un autre pays ça
serait même pas l'Allemagne ça serait
pas l'Espagne ce serait peut-être
davantage la Grande-Bretagne parce que
c'est une puissance de thé parce que
c'est une puissance maritime parce que
c'est une puissance qui a eu aussi des
Outre-mer dans une autre d'autres
régimes ce que le commonweal c'est une
alliance politique nous nous encore des
territoires de souveraineté vous avez
cité la Nouvelle-Calédonie donc bon donc
on y reviendra mais je le dis pour le
coup à dessin notre modèle est bien
français comme il est bien français ne
cherchons pas à le à le comparer en
revanche on peut essayer de le comparer
dans le temps par rapport à avant bon
est-ce que notre modèle d'armée
aujourd'hui
peut nous permettre de remporter toutes
les batailles la réponse est non c'est
bien pour ça que le programmation
militaire va venir et apporter des
réponses tout simplement parce qu'il y a
des nouveaux espaces de conflictualité
le spatial l'espace devient un endroit
dans lequel la militarisation progresse
à vitesse grand V les fonds sous-marins
le cyber le détournement d'objets civils
à des fins méditer dans le cadre de
l'hybridité donc la réalité au fait
c'est quelles sont les véritables
menaces qui planent ou qui pèsent sur la
nation française et le modèle d'armée et
l'argent qu'on doit y mettre en face
mais pas que l'argent d'ailleurs les
politiques de ressources humaines la
préparation du corps social français la
résilience de manière globale les forces
morales quelle est la préparation que
l'on doit mettre en fonction des menaces
et et des menaces wikipé sur la sur la
nation française et donc c'est pour ça
que je pèse souvent contre les
comparaisons avec l'Ukraine ou alors ce
serait que tout l'oeuvre des gaullistes
dans les années 60 sur la dissuasion
nucléaire sur le fait d'être une
puissance de thé coûte que coûte
n'aurait servi à rien et ça pour le coup
je pense que dans notre dissuasion il
faut aussi que les parlementaires les
ministres les signes tanks les édits
réexplique aussi ce que c'est qu' est
une puissance de d par exemple pour
défendre ses intérêts vitaux merci
Monsieur le Ministre alors je ne vois
personne de la France insoumise et
j'espère d'ailleurs que ben c'est un
choix de garde pas un trop mauvais
souvenir de sa dernière question lors de
votre précédente audition et j'en
profite pour donner la parole à Fabien
Roussel qui devra nous quitter plus
prématurément je vous remercie monsieur
le Président effectivement j'ai tout
fait pour pouvoir être là aujourd'hui
dans cette journée un peu particulière
mes chers collègues monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre
pour nous c'est clair la folie guerrière
déclenchée voici un an porte un nom
celui de Vladimir Poutine il n'y a
aucune ambiguïté pour nous dans ce
conflit il y a bien un agresseur je
viens de le citer et un PA un pays en
état de légitime défense auquel nous
devons apporter tout notre soutien bien
sûr il sera temps le moment venu de
s'interroger sur le rôle la
responsabilité de l'OTAN des États-Unis
des pays qui ont toujours poussé leur
base aux frontières de la Russie et
provoquer le pouvoir russe mais la
réalité en tout cas est là la Russie a
violé l'intégrité territoriale d'un pays
l'Ukraine nous devons pour cela
forcément aider l'Ukraine la population
ukrainienne à se défendre à protéger ses
civils à empêcher les bombes russes de
tomber sur les maternités les écoles les
hôpitaux mais c'est surtout avant tout
ce que nous disons tout doit être mis en
oeuvre pour mettre fin à cette guerre au
plus vite ne pas nous inscrire dans un
conflit long par la voie politique et
diplomatique par la négociation avec
comme objectif de faire respecter
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Ukraine
car tout le monde l'affirme responsable
politique comme militaire il n'y a
aucune issue militaire à cette guerre
mettant en jeu d'immenses puissances y
compris nucléaire la seule issue sera
donc la négociation or ces dernières
semaines des tabous ont été levés de la
livraison de charlour jusqu'à l'envoi
tout récemment de système de guidage
américain permettant de transformer des
bombes en missiles longues portées une
telle escalade si elle devait se
poursuivre irait à l'encontre de notre
volonté initiale de ne pas devenir
cobelligérant je pose une question la
France prend-elle le risque d'entrer en
guerre demain
et pour pouvoir débattre de cette
question nous avons demandé à la
première ministre l'organisation à
l'Assemblée nationale d'un débat sur le
rôle de la France sur les livraisons
d'armes sur sa stratégie politique
diplomatique pour aboutir à un cesser le
feu et l'ouverture de négociation entre
l'Ukraine et la Russie pour le groupe
communiste le groupe GDR le retour à la
paix au respect des peuples et à leur
territoire à la sécurité collective de
tous les peuples d'Europe sont nos
priorités et le peuple français par le
biais de son parlement doit pouvoir être
associé à nos choix tellement la
question est importante et grave merci
monsieur le député merci pour votre
présence et la clarté du propos
sur le fait d'associer le le Parlement
je pense que c'est clé je pense qu'on a
besoin de transparence on a besoin
d'explications on en fera jamais assez
ce sont des sujets en plus qui sont
complexes malheureusement les réseaux
sociaux parfois les les caricatures donc
d'avoir du temps de déplier une pensée
et se débattre va dans le bon sens c'est
pour ça je vous remercie président de me
convoquer cet après-midi je ça ne vaut
pas un débat dans l'hémicycle avec la
première ministre en tout cas à mon
niveau j'essaie de répondre à l'ensemble
de vos questions un groupe de contact
aura lieu alors ce n'est pas un débat
dans l'hémicycle je je le conseille bien
volontiers mais un groupe de contact
aura lieu avec les différents présidents
de groupe je crois dans dix jours ce qui
permettra aussi d'ailleurs à nos états
majeurs au service de renseignement etc
de répondre à vos questions plus
techniques ce qu'on ne serait pas
forcément devant un micro sur évidemment
la situation tactique sur le terrain ce
que je pense aussi que c'est notre
devoir dans la mesure où on peut
répondre aux questions de la
représentation nationale d'éclairer
aussi sur la situation opérationnelle
militaire tel qu'on peut la connaître
donc merci pour la clarté deuxième des
choses vous avez raison il est évident
que un travail diplomatique et politique
doit se mener le sujet c'est le moment
et les conditions je le dis d'autant
plus que quelque soit nos opinions
politiques la France a toujours été à la
manœuvre forme un Normandie avec les
Allemands avec des efforts on pense ce
qu'on veut mais des efforts importants
évidemment qui se sont déployés ensuite
les allers-retours du président de la
République entre Kiev et Moscou avant le
début de l'agression participer au fond
je crois à une forme de consensus dans
le pays parmi les sensibilités
politiques parce que l'histoire de la
France et la voix de la France c'est
quand même toujours de justement ne
jamais céder l'escalatatoire et de
toujours permettre à la politique et la
diplomatie de faire son œuvre et puis
évidemment on est dans un moment dans
lequel
la situation sur le terrain est tendue
elle est difficile on le sait bon et
pour autant on voit quand même des jeux
d'acteurs qui qui évoluent pas ne pas
parler de la Chine bon si le président
de la République part bientôt en Chine
c'est aussi parce que ça permettra aussi
de développer un dialogue plus global et
je dis ceci bien volontiers tous les
pays de l'hémisphère sud parce que ça
devient aussi parfois une affaire trop
occidentale donc il faut aussi
évidemment associer la plupart des
partenaires donc à votre interpellation
sur le la place du politique et de la
diplomatie dans le règlement du conflit
il y a une permanence française
évidemment autour de ce constat
parce que je veux évidemment réaffirmer
ici bon après c'est aussi aux Ukrainiens
de donner les différents paramètres de
discussions et de négociation et pour
cause vous l'avez dit avec beaucoup de
clarté je vous en remercie une fois de
plus ils sont les agressés et donc c'est
à eux aussi évidemment définir les
contours des discussions c'est ce qu'on
dira d'ailleurs aussi un certain nombre
de pays qui peuvent jouer des rôles dans
cette affaire là ensuite Charles lourd
je le disais en introduction bon déjà
une arme est une arme donc c'est quand
même certaines armes sont purement
défensifs je parlais de la défense seul
r certaines armes c'est la doctrine
d'emploi de l'arme qui fait qu'elle est
offensive vous défensive bon moi j'ai
pas beaucoup aimé la notion de charlour
parce que ça sous-entendrait qu'un char
serait plus lourd qu'un César plus
l'étal qu'un César ou qu'un Léo
tactiquement sur le terrain c'est pas
vrai
on est sur des
segments d'armement qui sont des
segments d'armements qui sont tous
lourds donc sous-entendre qu'il y aurait
des armes vous l'avez pas fait mais je
le refais pour ceux qui nous écoutent
qui auraient des armes légères et des
armes lourdes c'est techniquement pas
vrai bon ça je pense que ce qui compte
c'est la meilleure on est Ukrainiens
s'en servent pour quelle bataille pour
quelle manœuvre sur le terrain pour
qu'elle contre-offensive et je le disais
en introduction pour le coup dans le
dialogue que nous avons avec musique
crânien à chaque fois il est clairement
dit que les matériels qui sont donnés
par la République française à l'Ukraine
sont là dans le cadre de leur légitime
défense et je le redis devant vous cet
après-midi
oui effectivement monsieur le ministre
ce groupe de liaison aura lieu pile dans
une semaine puisqu'il se tiendra
mercredi prochain de 18 à 21h et
l'ensemble des présidents de groupes
politiques et présente commission auront
l'occasion de débattre en tout cas
d'échanger avec la première ministre
pendant plus de 3h pour le groupe les
républicains la parole est à Christelle
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je tiens tout d'abord à vous
remercier au nom du groupe les
républicains pour votre présence
aujourd'hui à nos côtés et d'avoir pris
de votre temps pour répondre à nos
questions mes interrogations porteront
sur la fourniture d'avions de combat
mirage dans le cadre de l'aide française
à l'Ukraine le 30 janvier dernier le
président de la République a annoncé à
ce propos que par définition rien n'est
exclu nous avons eu des échos de plus en
plus importants à ce sujet le mois
dernier mais la situation semble la
changer l'Ukraine ayant perdu près de 57
aéronefs depuis le début du conflit vous
indiquez vous-même qu'il n'y avait pas
de tabou et tout porte à croire et bien
que la France s'apprête à briser ce
tabou de l'envoi d'avion de combat nous
le savons l'aide française à l'Ukraine
ne doit faire suite à une demande
formulée par les Ukrainiens sans risque
escalatoires et pas de nature à toucher
le sol russe mais bien à aider l'effort
de résistance sans que ce soutien ne
vienne affaiblir la capacité de l'armée
française comme vous en avez parlé dans
votre propos introductif car si la
France venait à fournir des avions de
combat il faudrait s'assurer que nous
répond à ces critères de cession
d'armement en veillant aux besoins réels
de tels appareils par les ukrainiens et
en prenant considération le risque
escalatoires que cela impliquerait de
plus le volume de notre flotte d'avion
de combat ne mérite peut-être pas un tel
sacrifice et il faudrait veiller à
l'utilité des 113 mirages de l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace pouvant encore
profiter à nos armées en somme l'envoi
d'avion de combat représenterait un
grand pas dans l'effort de guerre en
Ukraine et les risques laissent augurer
un nouveau paradigme dans le conflit le
chancelier allemand a laissé savoir
qu'il était opposé à cette idée au
moment où le Royaume-Uni donnait son
accord pour la formation de pilote
ukrainien tout cela soulève de
nombreuses questions et nous en sommes
en droit et bien de nous demander si
nous ne faisons pas face à une ligne
rouge depuis le début du conflit les
alliés de l'Ukraine s'emploie à ne pas
lui fournir d'armement capable de
frapper de frapper les Russes sur leur
territoire or un avion de combat serait
capable de les frapper au-delà des
frontières de l'Ukraine le risque est
bien réel la rhétorique de menaces de
Moscou la bien compris en
en prédisant des conséquences militaires
pour le continent européen dans un tel
scénario ainsi Monsieur le Ministre mon
précisionnement est donc le suivant où
en est-on de la fourniture d'avion de
combat Mirage à l'Ukraine en cas de
fourniture de ses appareils seront-ils
vendus ou donner et qu'en est-il de la
formation des pilotes craignants sur ces
avions de chasse je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour vous répondre très
directement bon pas de tabou ça veut
dire pas de tabou politique parce
qu'après tout pourquoi exclure une arme
plus qu'une autre que je le redis c'est
ce que l'on fait de l'avion qui est
défensif ou offensif on pourrait dire la
même chose pour les missiles vous pouvez
détourner un missile Aster d'un sante
pour faire de la défense solaire et en
faire une arme offensive tournée vers un
vers une cible autre donc je pense qu'il
faut que les commissaires à la défense
ici on revient aussi au fond à la
doctrine d'usage des arbres non je pense
que là vous l'avez dit vous même dans la
dans votre question le vrai sujet c'est
la la faisabilité technique
opérationnelle je pense que c'est
plusieurs mois de formation
la flotte d'avion de chasse de l'armée
française n'est pas infinie
c'est pas seulement un aviateur c'est
pratiquement une dizaine d'aviateurs
entre évidemment les pilotes mais
également ce qu'on appelle le plot sur
lequel évidemment les mécaniciens etc le
MCO sur un avion des redoutablement
complexes bon donc moi je suis
transparent avec vous les priorités que
je me suis assigné et que j'ai assigné
au ministère c'est comme je disais tout
à l'heure la défense solaire en plus
protection du champ de bataille
protection des infrastructures civiles
et des civiles et je pense que là-dessus
il y a du consensus pour que la France
fasse de gros efforts pour qu'on aille
plus vite encore pour le faire et sur le
segment des matériaux terrestres puisque
les contre-offensives qui elles sont bel
et bien légitimes défenses parce qu'il y
aura pas de débat là aussi parmi les
différentes sensibilités politiques en
tout cas je le dis pour voir si on a un
nous permettra évidemment de répondre à
cette affaire là quand le ministre reste
nicov est venu présentation peut aussi
en témoigner parce qu'il y a eu des
contacts aussi au niveau parlementaire
dans les discussions que nous avons avec
eux c'est sur la défense solaire et je
vais peut-être pas assez insisté je ne
m'en excuse dans mon propos liminaire
sur les munitions que nous sommes
attendus souvent des munitions pour du
matériel qu'on a déjà donné je pense
notamment aux obus de 155 mm donc
cette fiabilité à la française aussi
nous permet de nous inscrire dans un
temps beaucoup plus long sur lequel au
fond il nous faut être endurance sur ce
qui est déjà demandé merci monsieur le
ministre pour le groupe démocrate la
parole est à Josy poeto oui merci
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre moi aussi
je tiens à vous remercier une fois de
plus pour votre disponibilité pour les
informations partagées avec les membres
de notre commission le soutien à
l'Ukraine est un enjeu majeur qui prend
de plus en plus d'importance alors que
la guerre est s’inscrit dans la durée
alors que les forces
ukrainiennes consomment plus de mon
munitions que l'industrie de défense
européenne n'est capable d'en produire
Bruxelles a incité les Etats européens à
faire davantage de commandes communes
loin des armements très sophistiqués
dans lesquels les entreprises françaises
tendent à se spécialiser et de
l'excellence échantillonnaire de la
France cette guerre montre que les
besoins des Ukrainiens sont plus
basiques et qu'il est préférable de se
concentrer sur quelques types
d'armements afin de faciliter la
formation des soldats et la prise en
main des équipements quelles leçons les
armées et les industries françaises de
défense vont-elles en tirer
le soutien à l'Ukraine a également
marqué la réunion de Stockholm des
ministres de la Défense en résumé je
retiens que l'Europe a trouvé un accord
pour engager 2 milliards d'euros dans
des munitions dont un milliard pour
rembourser des États qui auront fourni
directement le matériel à l'Ukraine les
marchés à lancer sont supervisés par
l'agent européenne de la défense les
alliés européens ont promis ou déjà
donné autour de 35 milliards d'euros
selon les données reprises par les
médias la France pour sa part aurait
alimenté l'aide européenne à hauteur de
ces milliards sans les remettre en cause
évidemment des sommes en jeu sont
considérables comme bien même celle le
signe serait qu'une évaluation de
journalistes qui n'ont peut-être pas
connaissance de l'ensemble des soutiens
et de leur coûts s'ajoutent par ailleurs
d'autres sommes à la lecture et des
classements des pays cette fois
directement donateurs dans cette
catégorie la France se placerait ainsi à
la sixième place mondiale avec un
exercice d'euros mais dans ce cas les
sessions militaires françaises ne
seraient pas rentabiliser tout cela
devient particulièrement complexe
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
apporter quelques éléments plus précis
avez-vous déterminé le montant exact des
engagements français à ce jour par
ailleurs alors que de multiples acteurs
interviennent au fil des étapes dans les
flux d'argent public en jeu pensez vous
que la représentation nationale dispose
de toutes les garanties pour exercer sa
mission de contrôle de parlementaire
cette mission de contrôle est une valeur
pilier du groupe démocrate auquel
j'appartiens c'est pourquoi en creux ma
question en soulève une autre les
députés de la commission de la défense
disposeront-ils un jour d'un niveau
d'habilitation de nature à leur assurer
le niveau de contrôle nécessaire je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup bon 2 minutes c'est
compliqué de prendre tous les sujets
j'imagine même la député alors
comme vous avez tous la gentillesse de
souligner le fait que je reviens devant
vous je vous fais la promesse de revenir
de nouveau et sur les sujets de contrôle
du Parlement peut-être de l'évoquer dans
le cadre de loi de programmation
militaire ce que vous savez il y a un
article de la LPM qui aussi très rare de
du sujet du contrôle donc on pourrait y
revenir et j'indiquer aussi tout à
l'heure dans mon propos que évidemment
lors de la séance aussi dédiée aux
exportations d'armes il va sans dire que
pour cet exercice 2023 j'aurai
l'occasion de présenter aussi évidemment
un certain nombre d'éléments au
Parlement sur sur les sessions d'armes à
l'Ukraine bon sur le retour d'expérience
on a déjà commencé à en parler lors de
la dernière audition consacrée aux
travaux préparatoires de la
programmation militaire je pense qu'il y
a beaucoup beaucoup d'éléments de retour
d'expérience à voir à votre question
était beaucoup plus précise elle disait
retour d'expérience pour les industriels
je reviens pas sur l'économie de guerre
je reviens pas sur la réactivité dès
lors que au fond notre BITD est
imbriquée dans notre appareil de défense
il va sans dire que la gestion des des
sous-traitants des stocks de
l'organisation de la prévisibilité etc
est un enjeu absolument clé sur lequel
on aura l'occasion de revenir non je
pense qu'il y a aussi un enjeu sur la
soutenabilité économique tel que
prendre un missile qui coûte un million
d'euros pour aller à battre un drone qui
coûte 50 000 dollars
c'est un non sens évidemment en termes
de soutenabilité voilà je le pose là
c'est un des énormes enjeux qui nous
attendent pour la LPM donc une
proportionnalité des instruments et du
matériel par rapport à ce qui est engagé
et ça en plus on peut pas le faire seul
parce que faut aussi regarder évidemment
quels sont les armes que l'on peut
trouver en face de nous dans des
conflits divers et variés éventuels et
évidemment les 20 ans de lutte contre le
terrorisme armé que nous avons connu
nous a donné une expérience sur un
certain nombre de types d'armements qui
n'a rien à voir avec un engagement
majeur éventuel bon et encore une fois
que j'ai dit ça qu'est-ce que nous
français on prend et qu'est-ce qu'on se
partage en coalition parce que ce qu'on
a vocation à tout prendre même les
Américains ne le font pas donc pourquoi
nous le ferions nous et on en aurait pas
les moyens donc voilà donc je pense que
pardon je laisse le sujet ouvert parce
que il va évidemment infuser l'ensemble
de la discussion de la LPM en semure il
faudra évidemment qu'on y prenne le
temps facilite européenne de paix
globalement 650 millions d'euros plus
400 millions d'euros donc le chiffre que
vous avez indiqué on en est pas très
loin le fond de soutien et quant aux
sessions on les a pas chiffrées parce
que ça ne semble pas indispensable
d'autant plus que chiffrer un matériel
neuf qui va faire l'objet de
recomplétude on sait le faire chiffrer
un vieux TRF1 qu'on n'aurait jamais
remplacé par ailleurs je pense que ça
n'aurait pas de sens non plus pour être
transparent
merci monsieur le ministre pour le
groupe socialiste la parole est à
Isabelle Santiago
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci pour
vos éclairages je voulais
vous deux minutes en fait je vais aller
directement à ma question
pour essayer d'être dans ce qu'on essaie
de mettre en place c'est à dire un
dialogue ou on pose la question et on se
répondent qui avait été décidé en bureau
juste suite à la réunion à Stockholm
auquel vous avez participé avec les
ministres de la Défense monsieur le
ministre au sein de l'Union européenne
vous faites partie donc il y a eu les
questions autour de ce qu'il y avait été
abordé par Joseph Borel sur la demande
au sein de livrer 2500
000 pardons obus et à l'armée
ukrainienne dans les plus brefs délais
et donc du coup je voulais avoir un
retour sur l'ensemble des points que
vous pouvez nous dire évidemment en
commission sur cette semaine à Stockholm
sur les échanges que vous avez pu avoir
puisque plusieurs sujets ont été abordés
dont l'Agence européenne de défense les
commandes la formation en commun voilà
si vous avez sans être le secret défense
mais qu'on puisse avoir un retour sur
cette réunion qui a fait pas mal
d'articles de presse et sur lequel on
voulait un peu échanger au-delà des
articles et de ce qui pourrait être dit
par vous
merci beaucoup alors bon beaucoup de
sujets évidemment européens sont dans
l'atmosphère on va continuer d'ailleurs
lundi à Bruxelles avec la ministériel
affaire étrangère et défense donc là les
deux ministres de chaque pays membre de
l'UE bon il y a toujours les discussions
autour de la fête parce que tout ça se
fait pas tout seul évidemment faut
l'avancer parce que tout le monde est
d'accord pour contribuer mais enfin la
pérennité évidemment du fond est un des
enjeux qui compte beaucoup pour nous il
est sujet parfois d'ailleurs que nous
avions lancé nous-mêmes sous président
françaises comme Idir pas qui donne déjà
un peu la culture d'achat en commun donc
ça renvoie à votre question plus précise
sur les achats que nous pouvons faire de
manière groupée ça c'est clair parce que
l'effet de levier évidemment est
autrement plus fort
ça pose des questions de l'organisation
de la bitde et évidemment des
concurrences qui peuvent exister au sein
des entreprises évidemment au sein de
l'Union européenne c'est sain mais faut
le traiter évidemment et très vite en
fait on voit qu'un sujet est en train de
monter mon avis il est intéressant en
termes de souveraineté globale partagée
du plateau continental européen c'est
évidemment l'accès à certaines matières
premières la poudre pour donner un
exemple très précis très concret on peut
faire toutes les toutes les décisions
d'achat en commun d'obus ou de munitions
au bout d'un moment est-ce qu'on a
suffisamment de poudre disponibles sur
le continent européen pour alimenter
l'ensemble des entreprises qui sont en
situation de pouvoir fabriquer des
munitions de quelques calibres que ce
soit bon ça c'est typiquement un vrai
sujet et c'est un beau sujet de repérant
parce que là pour le coup on sait pas
concurrence entre nous c'est une
capacité tout simplement exister sur
l'ensemble de la de la planète pour être
en situation de sanctuariser un certain
nombre de stocks et le dernier élément
pour essayer de tenir mes deux minutes
ce sont bien sûr les sujets de
financement parce qu'il y a pas de vie
économique sans un moment donné accès à
un certain nombre de financement on voit
bien les sujets de taxonomie les sujets
de d'accompagnement bancaire dans
l'investissement ou l'autofinancement
que nous entreprises de la bit des E et
donc de la bit des françaises avec les
difficultés qui sont les leurs en la
matière méritent aussi une discussion
entre européen parce que parfois il y a
une commission qui qui peut à mon avis
évoluer sur ces sujets en tout cas moi
je tiens à rendre hommage publiquement
au commissaire breton sur les
initiatives qui sont qui sont prises
parce qu'elles vont dans le bon sens et
on commence à attirer quand même des
conclusions de ce qui se passe en
Ukraine aussi à l'échelle européen merci
monsieur le ministre le groupe horizon
la parole est à Jean-Charles l'arseneur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais pour commencer à
avoir une pensée pour les deux salariés
grièvement blessés dans une usine de
Nexter
associant à cette pensée les collègues
du groupe horizon et saga mon collègue
Loïc Cabran
je veux dire ensuite que l'armée
ukrainienne souffre la résiste mais elle
souffre elle manque d'hommes
singulièrement
elle manque d'équipements ensuite
il faut bien réaliser qu'une
contre-offensive victorieuse supposerait
aujourd'hui
des centaines de chars
probablement des dizaines ou des
centaines d'avions des centaines de
milliers de munitions tout calibre au
regard de l'engagement majeur constitue
cette guerre ce type d'engagement
aujourd'hui
je veux saluer les initiatives
françaises singulièrement la manœuvrer
réussie sur la mx-10rc qui a eu un effet
d'entraînement réel je crois sur nos
partenaires européens
j'aurais aimé que nous réitérions la
manœuvre sur Leclerc non pas parce que
c'est la flotte la plus adaptée mais
parce que peut-être aussi ça veut un
effet d'entraînement significatif
pour les chars lourds et les choses
avancent des remèdes avec la flotte de
léopard qui est pour l'Europe la plus
adaptée comme les Abrahams au plan
américain
je voudrais vous poser deux questions la
première sur le niveau d'ambition que
nous fixons aujourd'hui à date en
matière d'aviation sur les cibles en
matière de mirage que nous pourrions
éventuellement céder sur les cibles en
matière d'entraînement et sur les délais
que nous envisageons
et la deuxième sur les questions cyber
une demande qui m'est souvent faite par
les collègues homologues députés
Ukrainiens
en s'appuyant notamment sur
un organisme qui existe qui la
plateforme cyber
Ukraine autant alors qui est un peu
méconnu ici
mais qui serait une plateforme
intéressante à la fois pour arrimer
encore davantage l'Ukraine dans le temps
et pour aller plus loin dans notre
coopération en matière de cybersécurité
et de cyber-enseignements je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup sur le sur les avions je
pense avoir déjà globalement bien tracé
les éléments de de position de la France
d'autant plus que je le redis c'est je
ne sens pas dans mes discussions avec
nos partenaires Ukrainiens que nous
sommes attendus on pourrait tout à fait
clair donc j'y reviens pas je les
largement détaillé les chats déjà la
mx-10rc
il est ils sont arrivés
donc évidemment un premier paquet de
chars moi je suis en train évidemment de
de regarder comment on peut
éventuellement faire une deuxième une
deuxième vague de session le cas échéant
je suis en train de préparer un certain
nombre de décisions pour le président de
la République parce que ces chars
commencent à être bien pris en main par
par le partenaire ukrainien certains
sont déjà partis sur la ligne de front
alors ce que je disais tout à l'heure la
notion de Charles léger charlour est un
peu lunaire parce que je veux dire ça
reste des armes en tant que tel et j'en
reviens pas le aussi sur ce que j'ai pu
dire Charles Leclerc je pense que
malheureusement avec beaucoup d'humilité
je pense qu'on n'aurait pas entraîné
grand chose pour être très direct pour
deux raisons la première c'est que pour
entraîner il aurait déjà fallu exporter
et qu'au fond c'est un des forces du
chariotard c'est que la coalition
léopard comme on dit elle existe parce
que beaucoup de pays européens disposent
de ces charges et donc au-delà des
décisions allemandes dans la matière il
y a un effet d'entraînement y compris
avec des pays de l'Europe qui parfois
ont pu en donner trois quatre à la
mesure de ce qu'ils peuvent faire il
faut le respecter donc évidemment faut
exportations le char Leclerc son
exportation a été timide
peut en témoigner donc évidemment
l'effet d'entraînement sur des
partenaires à l'export était proche de
zéro la deuxième des choses c'est qu'on
ne produit plus en fait ça n'a pas été
dit aussi clairement dans les médias et
ça je profite de votre question pour le
dire ici vous le savez mais je le dis
c'est que on parle des Abrahams les
chars qui ont été promis par les
États-Unis d'Amérique sont pas des
charges et fut de cession de l'armée
américaine mais des lignes de
construction de chars et donc ce sont
des chars neufs qui vont arriver nous on
aurait donné des chars Leclerc on les
aurait on n'aurait pas pu faire de
recomplétude donc ça je réexplique cela
parce que ça explique beaucoup de choses
sur la décision évidemment que nous
avons prise ont cru qui est pas un tabou
politique t'es pas mais qui est très
opérationnel et qui est très concrète 3
cybers c'est évidemment j'ai pas le
temps de répondre à toutes les questions
sur le rétexte secret mais voilà
évidemment un pas entier qui va mériter
que l'on s'y attelle pendant la loi de
programmation militaire
il y a beaucoup d'attaques cyber
évidemment dans le cadre du conflit
souvent un bas bruit d'ailleurs dans les
deux sens
avec d'ailleurs un courage ukrainien là
aussi qui est intéressant à noter avec
des coalitions internationales de
cyber-combattants aussi qui est
intéressant à à regarder qui pose
évidemment des questions aussi sur les
systèmes de de protection et de défense
que chaque pays doit développer parce
que comme il n'y a pas de frontières sur
le cyber l'enjeu évidemment de la
perception du risque et du danger ou de
la menace sécuritaire elle est elle est
clairement
vous avez parlé de l'OTAN pour être
honnête je le dis ici
publiquement je regrette que la question
cyber ne soit pas plus pris en charge et
mieux traiter au sein de l'agence
Atlantique voilà typiquement sur les
nouvelles menaces donc je pense que nous
Français il faut qu'on soit aussi ce
rapprocher des partenaires qui ont pris
de l'avance parce que les pays de balles
sont des pays intéressants sur la prise
en compte du sujet cyber depuis
maintenant de nombreuses années et là
pour le coup il y aura évidemment des
sujets à traiter avec eux en deux
minutes que j'ai largement exposé c'est
compliqué de répondre à tout merci
monsieur le ministre pour le groupe
liotte la parole est tapis à Morel à
l'huissier bien sûr monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre les chers
collègues tout d'abord je tiens à
commencer à en adressant au nom de mon
groupe un message de soutien d'effectif
à l'Ukraine et au peuple ukrainien après
un an de guerre notre pays a fait preuve
du mobilisation remarquable pour
soutenir l'Ukraine tant sur le plan
financier que sur le plan des livraisons
d'armes et de munitions je tiens
également à rendre hommage aux côtés de
l'action de nos armées à la mobilisation
citoyenne pour des réfugiés cependant
une question s'impose à nous et à nos
alliés souhaitons nous contribuer pour
seulement aider l'armée ukrainienne à
résister aux forces russes ou voulant
nous aller plus loin et lui donner les
moyens de riposter et de repartir à
l'offensive deux questions sur le
ministre d'avoir la question de la
livraison des avions de combat au fil
des mois de guerre nous avons vu les
tabous sur les livraisons d'armes tombés
les uns après les autres notre groupe ne
remet pas en cause les doutes ils
étaient légitimes mais le temps n'est
plus aux hésitations face à cette guerre
il faut désormais trouver une ligne unie
avec nos alliés et s'y tenir risque
d'envoyer un message chancelant à
l'Ukraine le seul ministre vous avez dit
que rien n'était exclu mais concrètement
allez vous franchir ce nouveau cap et
livrer des avions de combat on parle de
CD d'images de santé retiré récemment de
services à défaut quid de livraison
d'hélicoptère il pourrait être mobilisé
par des femmes ciblées le Royaume-Uni a
déjà fait un panse de sens nous
pourrions contribuer
il y a aussi la question sous-jacent de
la formation deuxième question l'Europe
de la défense notre politique européenne
de défense a longtemps été limitée et
s'est réveillé brutalement avec le
config ukrainien en dépit des annonces
les processus sont lents je vais prendre
un exemple précis l'Ukraine demande la
livraison d'un million d'obus de calibre
157 ce qui devrait lui permettre de
tenir 6 à 10 mois au delà du couteau ne
peut pas demander au pays depuis et
indéfiniment dans leur propre stock
nationaux la contribution ne doit pas se
faire au détriment de notre propre armée
en ce sens on parle d'un achat commun en
commun piloté par l'Union concrètement
comment se présentera ce plan quel
soutien budgétaire européen pour
financer l'acquisition de ces nouveaux
obus et comment mobiliser notre
industrie de la défense et pour terminer
je voudrais remercier la commission de
la défense au nom des de la délégation
qui s'est rendu sur le porte-avion
Charles de Gaulle on a eu un accueil
fabuleux par les militaires et on a été
aussi du mot informé de des missions et
de la réactivité française et se tenait
à le dire aujourd'hui à la Commission
merci Monsieur
en complément de ce que j'ai déjà dit
pour
c'est le jeu de évidemment de principe
de l'audition à Avion j'y reviens pas
j'ai été précis là vous avez raison de
pointer que l'important c'est la
dimension ligne unie doctrine en tout
cas convergente à la rigueur de l'ignuni
on va dire la doctrine la plus
convergente possible
bon je crois déjà qu'il faut pas qu'on
s'aide aux effets de mode moi je l'ai
suffisamment dénoncé mais la mode de la
défense sol r dans tout le monde du mois
de décembre ensuite au mois de janvier
et plus personne ne parle défense
solaire alors que c'est pourtant
l'actualité opérationnelle tout le monde
parle de char avec on sait pas pourquoi
des chars qui seraient des chars légers
qui seraient des charlourds terminaisons
complètement étonnante et stupéfiante
ensuite c'est le mois des avions bon je
pense que il faut qu'on remettre
effectivement de la méthode ne serait-ce
que par respect vis-à-vis de nos
opinions publiques qui vont évidemment
ne pourrait ne plus comprendre pourquoi
on fonctionne par à coup là on est bel
et bien dans un effort de temps long
voilà donc l'avion et les avions je je
renvoie ce que j'ai précédemment dit et
que moi je considère que la défense
solaire et ce qui me préoccupe le plus
au moment où je vous parle parce que
c'est une nécessité tant pour le champ
de bataille et protéger et la défense et
les contrefensives
Ukrainiennes en légitime défense que les
infrastructures et évidemment on peut
plus civile donc ça je pense que c'est
un point sur lequel voilà je peux plus
directe en clair le calendrier de
livraison du 100e et quelque chose qui
me préoccupe et qui me mobilise beaucoup
avec les Italiens pour qu'on soit
capable de le déployer le plus vite
possible comme d'ailleurs les Américains
sont en train de le faire sur le
patriote et ça pour le coup c'est il y a
une urgence là pour le coup elle est
identifié et ça répond à mon avis à
votre à votre inquiétude en tout cas
votre interpellation Europe de la
défense bon je crois qu'il faut pas
qu'on se là aussi les choses avancent
malgré tout enfin
s'il y a quelques années on s'était
parlé théoriquement la facilité
européenne de paix de voir en si peu de
temps les choses se déployer la capacité
à aussi prendre des sanctions en commun
et des paquets de sanctions de manière
unanime notre capacité à porter aussi
l'adhésion de de deux pays nouveaux à
l'OTAN qui sont des pays évidemment en
lien avec le plateau continental
européen enfin bref je
suis plutôt modéré sur ces sujets comme
vous le savez ou des vieux gaullistes
mais néanmoins je vois quand même des
choses avancées sur les obus de 155 je
l'ai dit évidemment je les ai Borel et
un certain nombre de partenaires ce qui
compte c'est la capacité à produire
c'est l'accès à la poudre l'accès aux
chaînes de production et notre capacité
à tenir des rythmes de cadence de
production ça c'est véritablement
l'enjeu européen et donc la capacité à
dégager des stocks importants pour être
capable de produire de manière fiable et
linéaire pour être en capacité des
Ukraine ça c'est évidemment une des
préoccupations que nous avons
actuellement entre européen donc des
échanges ont commencé et on va continuer
évidemment d'en discuter encore lundi
prochain à Bruxelles merci Monsieur le
Ministre enfin dernière intervention de
groupe avec Bastien Lachaud pour le
groupe la France insoumise
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'étais retenu en hémicycle
pour un vote essentiel sur la fusion
IRSN ASN et donc la sûreté nucléaire du
pays et d'ailleurs nous devenons de
faire échec au gouvernement sur sur ce
point donc
mais comme j'ai vu que ma présence mon
absence vous manquez je j'ai accouru et
je tenais à rassurer monsieur le
monsieur le Président le seul mauvais
souvenirs de la dernière réunion est un
ministre qui répond en déformant le
programme d'une opposition ou alors qui
a démontré qu'il ne l'avait mal lu
plutôt ou pas compris mais je ce serait
faire insultes à votre intelligence et
je n'en suis et je n'en suis pas là
et donc je voulais déjà sur cette
question de l'Ukraine qui est une chose
sérieuse au nom du groupe de la France
insoumise de nupes à réaffirmé notre
total soutien aux ukrainiennes et aux
Ukrainiens dans leur lutte contre
l'agresseur russe et pour l'intégrité
territoriale de leur pays notre aide est
cruciale et je tiens à souligner
l'effort particulier qu'a fait la France
en la matière en parallèle rappelons que
tout doit être fait pour revenir à la
paix le plus rapidement possible et que
le retrait russe des territoires
illégalement occupés depuis le début de
l'invasion est un préalable
monsieur le ministre j'aurais donc deux
questions précises sur les sur notre
aide je souhaiterais vous interroger et
vous venez d'évoquer la question des
obus de 155 sur notre partenariat avec
l'Australie
il s'agit là d'un besoin crucial
souligné par tous les observateurs
pouvez-vous nous faire un point d'étape
sur ce partenariat vous avez indiqué que
les premières livraisons auraient lieu
au cours du premier trimestre 2023 qu'en
est-il quelle est la cible de production
et de livraison attendue
ensuite je souhaiterais parler du futur
de notre soutien j'ai bien pris note que
vous aviez reçu l'autorisation du
président de la République et de la
première ministre pour sortir de la LPM
les dépenses relatives à l'aide apporté
aux Ukrainiens et vous l'avez réaffirmé
devant notre commission à l'instant
toutefois la logique et le bon sens
voudrait que vous nous présentiez
prochainement un projet de loi de
programmation militaire avec des lignes
budgétaires directement affectées à des
sessions d'armement ou alors un autre
texte budgétaire avec ces lignes de de
session parce que force est de constater
que dans la conflictualité présente et
future ou la confrontation avec une
puissance dotée empêche tout engagement
qui irait au-delà de l'aide militaire et
financière les sessions d'armement sont
cruciales or celle-ci doivent être
prévues pour que l’on d’aubère pas nos
propres capacités
et que l'on puisse planifier y compris
l'utilisation des chaînes de production
de notre BITD dès lors allez vous
prévoir des crédits budgétaires pour
l'achat d'armement destiné à être cédé
ou non dans la LPM ou dans un autre
texte budgétaire je vous remercie merci
chemise merci beaucoup monsieur député
sur je commence peut-être par la fin bon
sur sorti delpm mais non je vous le
confirme ça veut donc dire que on
repasse en annuité budgétaire soit en
PLF soit en mode finance rectificative
classique et normale après on va quand
même retrouver des traces de cession
dans la LPM non pas sur le volet
budgétaire ça s'est sorti je le redis
mais évidemment sur le sur les cibles
alors après c'est là où il faudra qu'on
fasse le tri entre par honnêteté
intellectuelle entre les armes anciennes
dont on a au fond accéléré le retrait et
qui aurait quand même fait l'objet d'une
recomplétude je donne un exemple du
crotale peut-être que l'exemple le plus
le plus évident on a donc accéléré la
session d'écretal et donc accélère
l'achat des vmika donc ça ça correspond
une première famille et à chaque fois
j'en ferai la démonstration pour que ça
soit clair en termes de transparence et
évidemment la session d'armes neuves ou
il n'y avait pas de raison de les
retirer aussi vite les Césars et en
Surmont évidemment les plus connus des
armées de ces matériellement neufs ou là
pour le coup il y a une recomplétude sur
du matériel neuf donc j'ai envie de dire
par transparence on ira même jusqu'à ce
degré là parce que ça me semble ça
semble absolument évident que de que de
montrer cette affaire là
j'insiste aussi sur le fait que le fond
de soutien donc du bon parce que pour le
coup lui il est évident puisque c'est le
son j'en ai parlementaires qui le vote
en loi de finances ou le cas échéant ou
loi de finance rectificative et au moins
les choses sont claires et avec une
somme plafonnée et évidemment les 200
millions d'euros là ont été globalement
affectés donc j'ai pas eu le temps de
répondre à la question tout à l'heure je
m'en excuse et donc s'opposera
évidemment la question en lien avec le
Parlement de l'augmenter le cas échéant
bon sur les obus de 155 mm
c'est un enjeu majeur c'est un enjeu
européen c'est pour ça qu'on a eu cette
discussion avec les Australiens dans
lequel évidemment post post à faire dit
aucune on se parle beaucoup avec la
nouvelle équipe du gouvernement
albanaise et avec mon homologue ils ont
à cœur de faire des choses aussi utiles
pour l'Ukraine et nous en fait on s'est
aperçu que entre ceux qui ont le corps
des obus ceux qui ont les comment dire
les explosifs les explosifs et ceux qui
ont les poudres globalement ça nous
permet tout simplement soit de moins
prélever sur certains stocks surtout
simplement aussi réaccélérer certaines
productions je suis très précis par
exemple eux fournissent les expositifs
voilà ça c'est c'est ce qui nous permet
d'apporter là où Nexter au Racing avait
peut-être des enjeux justement
d'approvisionnement sur sur cette
affaire là donc on va on va nous accès
enfin grâce à cet accord avec
l'Australie ça nous permet donc
d'accélérer et de multiplier par deux la
livraison du nombre d'obus de la France
vers l'Ukraine on va on relève un peu le
risque parce que précisément on peut
produire plus voilà donc ça c'est
véritablement un exemple intéressant il
est pas en européen ça c'est factuel
mais ça veut dire aussi qu'en européen
doit aussi pouvoir imaginer des choses
assez similaires dans dans les temps qui
viendront au-delà des instruments tels
que ça a été rappelé qui sont proposés
par l'Union européenne ou la commission
là je pense qu'il y a un enjeu tout
simplement industriel de faire
rencontrer les différents stocks avec
les différentes lignes de production et
les différences sous-traitants c'est
aussi au fond un dépend très pratique de
l'économie de guerre
merci Monsieur ministre nous avons 13
questions individuelles et nous allons
les prendre de manière relativement
groupée pour essayer de gagner du temps
la parole est à Franck Giletti
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre depuis plusieurs
années la Chine et la Russie renforce
leur leur lien diplomatiques économique
et militaire au service de leur
contestation commune de l'ordre
international si ces derniers peuvent
apparaître unis au service de cette
cause les deux pays n'ont jamais
officialisé d'alliance la Chine étant
semblerait-il soucieuse de pas être tenu
responsable des actions du Kremlin de ce
fait la Chine n'a jamais condamné ni
soutenu directement là aussi dans son
effort de guerre pourtant récemment Tony
blinking le chef de la diplomatie
américaine a affirmé l'intention de la
République populaire de Chine de fournir
des armes à la Russie ce que Pékin
aussitôt réfuté outre les considérations
diplomatiques engendrées par un
potentiel soutien chinois à la guerre
mené par la Russie en Ukraine quelle
serait selon vous monsieur le ministre
les conséquences d'une telle entreprise
sur le champ de bataille plus encore si
la Chine venait à fournir en armes la
Russie cela pousserait-il la France à
renforcer son soutien à l'Ukraine et une
petite question subsidiaire aussi est-ce
que nos services avec le recul que nous
avons sur la guerre en Ukraine
maintenant qui date depuis un an ont une
vision sur la traçabilité de ces armes
légères qui peuvent être livrées à
l'Ukraine et qui pourraient aussi
alimenter le trafic d'armes au service
du terrorisme et enfin je rappelle juste
à Monsieur le Ministre qui a une semaine
on fait été l'anniversaire de la sortie
du commandement intégré le temps mais ce
n'est pas au gaulliste que vous êtes que
je vais faire cette offense merci merci
la parole est à Delphine
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre tout d'abord merci de vous
rendre aussi disponible auprès des
commissaires de la défense l'objectif
annoncé par Joseph Borel en février 2023
est claire il s'agit de former 30 000
soldats ukrainiens 10000 ont déjà été
formés ou reçoivent actuellement une
formation individuelle collective ou
spécialisée en Pologne ou en Allemagne
sur ces 15000 Ukrainiens la France en
formera 2000 dans un premier temps une
partie de ces formations s'effectuera en
France une autre en Pologne via le
déploiement de 150 militaires français
avec pour objectif de former 600 soldats
Ukrainiens chaque mois
l'objectif étant d'assurer l'autonomie
des Ukrainiens à terme pourriez-vous
s'il vous plaît nous préciser le champ
disciplinaire de ces formations qui sont
comme vous l'avez rappelé complémentaire
à celle de nos alliés combien de nos
militaires sont engagés dans ce
programme de formation sur quelle durée
au delà et sur les années à venir est-il
prévu de poursuivre cet accompagnement
en matière de formation militaire que ce
soit sur le plan opérationnel mais aussi
sur un plan plus stratégique en
intégrant des militaires Ukrainiens un
certain programme de formation dispensés
par nos grandes écoles militaires ou
civiles je vous remercie merci la parole
est à José et Gonzales
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en octobre dernier vous
annonciez que 2000 Ukrainiens 2000
soldats Ukrainiens serait formé en
France sur le maniement des armes et du
matériel que nous leur livrions objectif
d'autant plus nécessaire du fait de la
sophistication de certaines de nos
matériels les plus récents
mais aussi vous précisiez que ces
formations se verraient également plus
généraliste quant à la posture du
combattant tandis qu'elle concernerait
aussi la logistique parmi les besoins
identifiés par les Ukrainiens eux-mêmes
conscient de leur lacune d'ailleurs en
ce qui concerne l'armement par rapport à
l'agresseur russe je pense notamment en
formation d'artilleur sur le canon César
formation déjà entreprises à l'époque au
système de défense entière et un crotale
avec les systèmes solaires multicouche
justifié par la lutte antidrone et les
bons les bombardements aériens ainsi que
possiblement aux missiles sol tel que le
lance-roquette multiple si celui-ci leur
était livré en outre nous apprenions
tout récemment que la formation
accélérée dispensée aux militaire
ukrainien depuis un mois maintenant en
Allemagne et en Espagne quant à
l'utilisation des chars léopards 2
venait de s'achever
si les allemands semblent plutôt
satisfaits du résultat de cette
formation accélérée qu'en est-il les
entraînements dans ce voie chargé la
France des lacunes ont-elles été
identifiées nécessitant une formation
prolongée vous aviez toujours en octobre
dernier indiqué un délai de quelques
semaines d'entraînement pour ceux qui
concerne les soldats Ukrainiens
accueillis par nos unités
ces derniers sont-ils maintenant prêts
quels sont les retours de nos militaires
presque 5 mois plus tard et qu'est ce
que cela coûte à nos armées enfin si
l'objectif annoncé était de 2000 soldats
Ukrainiens combien en avons-nous à
présent former à ce jour
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
pour la réponse que vous allez nous
apporter merci la parole est à Yannick
Favennec Beko
merci monsieur le Président et merci
monsieur le ministre je me joins à la
voix de mes collègues pour souligner
votre disponibilité régulière devant
notre commission
la guerre du crâne confirme monsieur le
ministre le rôle préminant des drones en
particulier l'importance de disposer de
munitions téléopérée de coûts modérés
considérés comme des équipements
consommables au même titre que les
autres munitions pour autant un récent
rapport d'information sénatoriale
indique que 90% des petits drones
utilisés sont perdus les drones mâle
Reaper armés bien que très utile dans
des guerres asymétriques risquent d'être
difficilement exploitable dans un
contexte symétrique contenu de leur
vulnérabilité et de leur coût par
conséquent à la lumière du conflit
ukrainien et dans la perspective de la
culture loi de programmation militaire
pouvez-vous nous apporter des précisions
sur l'équipement de nos de nos unités
terrestres en engin non pilotés pour le
renseignement ou pour la frappe je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à Sabine
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre il y a quelques jours avec nos
partenaires étrangères et industriels a
eu lieu l'exercice spatial Astérix
visons à préparer nos armées à la gare
spatiale dans le cadre d'un conflit à
haute intensité alors nous avons vu au
début de la gare de crâne à quel point
l'espace était devenu un lieu
stratégique dans une guerre à haute
intensité le réseau Starling Space X a
permis à l'Ukraine de continuer à avoir
un accès à Internet et donc de maintenir
un lâche réseau de communication
notamment pour les militaires en février
dernier les députés européens ont voté à
la quasi unanimité en faveur de la
future constellation satellitaire iris 2
destiné à l'Internet au débit au sein de
l'Union européenne la France est quand
même un État membre important dans le
domaine spatial et je me réjouis
d'ailleurs de voir que le commandant de
l'espace va monter en puissance dans la
prochaine loi de
programmation militaire un an après le
début du conflit quel bilan pouvons-nous
en tirer dans le domaine spatial
militaire et est-ce que la France avec
nos partenaires européennes a apporté
une aide importante à l'Ukraine dans le
domaine spatial voici Monsieur le
Ministre pour cette première salle de 5
questions sachant que je vous précise
qui nous en restera deux salves merci
beaucoup
je vais essayer d'être le plus
synthétique possible monsieur le député
génétique sur la Chine
le massif française pour le coup elle
s'est exprimée clairement en disant
évidemment que la Chine ne devait pas
aider la Russie et je leur dis aider un
état agressé ou aider un état agresseur
je le redis parce que parfois des
comparaisons peuvent se faire de manière
un peu trop rapide évidemment ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas comparable il est clair
que la visite du président de la
République en Chine s'inscrit dans un
contexte tout à fait particulier qui va
nous permettre évidemment de regarder
quels sont au fond les efforts que la
Chine veut slash peut faire dans la
résolution du conflit on peut pas ne pas
voir que le plan de P a été mis sur la
table il est ce qu'il est il va sans
dire que il doit se faire avec les
Ukrainiens enfin voilà je pense que là
pour le coup il y a un dialogue
stratégique à amener et je me place pas
dans la situation dans lequel la Chine
aiderait la Russie mais en tout cas je
pense qu'il y a des efforts à mener avec
un dialogue et je pense que c'est le
rôle de la France de le faire
singulièrement et que d'ailleurs
peut-être que non seulement c'est son
rôle mais qu'en plus c'est peut-être
aussi celle qui a le plus de chance ou
de capacité pour arriver justement à
tenir un dialogue de qualité en la
matière traçabilité des armes c'est un
enjeu majeur on s'en parle entre allier
dans le format Rammstein notamment c'est
vrai sur les affaires de corruption
évidemment la traçabilité va souvent
malgré tout avec les avec les problèmes
de corruption alors la corruption il y a
aussi évidemment les armes que les
Russes pourraient récupérer et les
réinjecter dans d'autres théâtres c'est
évidemment le sujet que Wagner
évidemment peut nous poser où on peut
retrouver éventuellement demain des
armes sur le théâtre africain bon des
efforts importants sur lequel je rentre
pas dans les détails sont déployés tout
cas c'est identifiés c'est beaucoup
beaucoup d'efforts par les services de
renseignement par les Alliés et c'est
quelque chose sur lequel évidemment
sensibilise énormément les
Ukrainiens quand à la relation à le
temps merci Monsieur il ne faut pas non
plus que ça la vire un entier un
anti-américanisme primaire mais ce n'est
pas votre cas mais voilà j'ai bien pris
en tout cas même les députés et Monsieur
le Député vous êtes tous les deux
revenus sur les questions liées aux
formations qui me permet peut-être de
donner aussi quelque chose où il manque
sur lequel nous n'avons jamais
communiqué encore publiquement sur sur
ces sujets bon déjà en termes de
chiffres
on se donnait un nouvel objectif qui est
un objectif de 6000 soldats
Ukrainiens formés par la France sur ces
6000 monsieur le député je vous confirme
le chiffre de 2000 que je vous avais
indiqué 2000 sur le sol national dans
des unités des armées françaises et 4000
dans le cadre des missions de formation
que nous avons déployé en Pologne en
européen et souvent d'ailleurs en
franco-polonais je tiens d'ailleurs à en
hommage publiquement aux partenaires
polonais parce que on a noué une
intimité une réactivité et je je pense
que la relation entre Paris Varsovie est
importante pour l'avenir et donc là
aussi évidemment il y a des choses qui
sont en train de se de se déployer sur
les exemples de formation je vais tout
simplement prendre les dernières elles
ne vous surprendront pas on soit pour
l'utilisation soit pour la maintenance
du matériel donné typiquement les AMX
disrc ont donné lieu à un catalogue de
formation qui allait avec enfin
catalogue une offre de formation qu'elle
est avec on a peu parlé du MCO alors
qu'au fond c'est la grosse actualité du
moment et donc en fait on essaie aussi
nous de stimuler la formation de MCO ça
va avoir un combattant sur un matériel
c'est bien avoir le mécano qui va avec
c'est encore mieux si le combattant
lui-même peut être mécano sur certains
aspects ça peut aussi avoir du sens dans
le combat terrestre notamment on le fait
également évidemment sur le sante où je
vous rappelle que là pour le coup la
prise en main d'un dispositif comme
celui-ci est autrement plus complexe on
est sur la technologie qui est très fine
c'est quand même là pour le coup pas
sur le terrain ou pendant les formations
mais je dois être honnête les retours de
nos de nos soldats sont
extraordinairement positifs je le dis
pas gratuitement la capacité de
comprendre
la capacité de résilience d'imagination
des soldats Ukrainiens au contact de nos
matériels et au contact de nos soldats
ça fonctionne très bien voilà je dois
dire n'a pas d'alerte particulière et
c'est même plutôt le contraire monsieur
le député avec merci pour vos mots drone
ça sera évidemment un gros morceau de
programmation militaire alors maintenant
il va falloir qu'on arrive à casser le
mode drone en plusieurs morceaux parce
que un euro mal ou un ripper ou un
Patroller à plusieurs millions d'euros
c'est évidemment pas la même chose que
les munitions de téléopéraient ou les
essais de petit drone d'ailleurs
peut-être que nous d'ailleurs dans les
mots peut-être falloir aussi que dans la
langue française on commence à
développer peut-être des langages
nouveaux et c'est pour ça que parfois je
parlais de plus en plus de munitions
téléopérée c'est à dire en clair quelque
chose qui est jetable là où au fond
parfois d'autres drones sont des avions
tout simplement des avions sans pilote
mais on n'est plus du tout dans la même
gamme bon deuxième chose je le disais
tout à l'heure un missile ou un énorme
drone à plusieurs qui coûtent très cher
pour répondre à une menace qui elle
expose 30 000 euros ou 40 000 euros ça
n'a pas de sens donc ça ça va être
l'enjeu de la grille de proportionnalité
non pas que militaire mais aussi
économique sur sur la gamme des
matériels ça je pense que c'est
évidemment un sujet très important et
globalement on va je vous proposerai une
copie autour de 5 milliards d'euros sur
l'ensemble de la LPN uniquement sur la
question des drones
l'enjeu me semble-t-il étant donné que
nous avons pris un certain retard c'est
de ne pas chercher à rattraper le retard
mais à faire le saut d'une génération
technologique de se dire voilà
typiquement le Reaper romal très bien
sur les munitions de téléopérée plutôt
que d'aller sur des choses qui existent
déjà peut-être prendre notre risque et
développer quelque chose de bien made in
France qui correspond aussi à nos
théâtre et de contrats opérationnel
l'occasion de revenir vers vous
évidemment sur cette affaire là le
spatial l'autre grand sujet qui méritera
aussi des développements plus longs donc
j'y réponds de manière synthétique
déjà il y a les usages depuis l'espace
évidemment trouvent leur
rôle sur le conflit en Ukraine en plus
il y a pas de sujets de Kobe gérance
observer ce qui se passe en Ukraine
c'est pas une comédie gérant on a aussi
bon évidemment il y a aussi le les
usages parfois d'ailleurs d'objets
spatiaux civils que les Ukrainiens ou
les Russes peuvent avoir notamment tout
simplement le GPS je veux dire il va
sans dire que la capacité à s'orienter
avec un téléphone c'est aussi
l'application d'un usage spatial civil
dans votre poche donc cette enfin ça
dépend pour qui
pour nous je vous rassure les
le Guillaume n'est pas ouvert à tout le
monde bon donc en tout cas on aura
l'occasion évidemment d'y revenir je
vous ferai aussi évidemment les retours
sur les grands exercices du moment vous
avez cité Astérix j'aimerais aussi citer
Orion qui est quand même exactement non
mais qui fait partie quand même de
l'ensemble de la des grands
entraînements que l'armée française est
en train de mener et on peut pas parler
de le PM si on fait pas aussi le retour
d'expérience dans ses grands
entraînements quand ils seront terminés
et pendant la discussion de la
programmation militaire je viendrai
évidemment aussi devant vous pour vous
montrer ce qui fonctionne et ce qu'il
faut améliorer parce qu'un bon
entraînement c'est forcément montrer des
choses qui fonctionnent et des choses
qu'il faut améliorer merci de Monsieur
le Ministre la parole est à Charlotte
Gauthier bolognaise
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre il y a un peu plus d'un an
commencé le conflit en Ukraine nous
avons tous en tête des images marquantes
et le lourd tribu payé par les civils
Ukrainiens les pertes militaires sont
également très lourdes si les vides
évidemment impossible de dresser un
bilan exact d'autant plus en temps de
guerre où la surestimation ou
sous-estimation des morts et blessés est
une arme stratégique plusieurs sources
estiment les pertes dans l'armée
ukrainienne à 100 000 morts et blessés
si l'opinion publique s’alerte
aujourd'hui des pertes civiles et ce à
juste titre nous devons aussi nous
soucier de l'avenir des militaires
Ukrainiens la France a bien sûr un rôle
militaire et diplomatique à jouer dans
ce conflit nous disposons avec le
service de santé des armées d'un outil
exceptionnel et d'une expertise forte
sur la prise en charge des militaires
blessés en opération avec une chaîne
médicale complète au plus près des zones
de combat monsieur le ministre ma
question est simple est-ce que le SSA
fait bénéficier les Ukrainiens de ses
compétences précieuses pour les aider
sur le terrain à prendre en charge leur
blessés et si oui comment pourrait-on
caractériser le volet sanitaire de notre
soutien médical militaire à l'Ukraine je
vous remercie merci la parole est à
jean-philie pardon
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre tout d'abord permettez-moi de
vous remercier pour vos propos très
instructifs et très intéressant qui nous
éclaire sur la situation actuelle en
Ukraine depuis le déclenchement de cette
guerre il sur le territoire européen il
y a maintenant plus d'un an la France
par la voix du président de la
République a toujours apporté un soutien
fraternel et inconditionnel au peuple
ukrainien les nombreuses livraisons
d'armes de canon de munitions ou
d'équipements légers marque notre
attachement à la défense des Européens
et à la liberté des peuples de décider
par et pour eux-mêmes
l'Ukraine a régulièrement remercié la
France pour son engagement renouvelé
soutien d'autant plus important que le
conflit risque malheureusement de
s'inscrire dans la durée
pour maintenir dans le temps cet effort
à l'Ukraine et assurer notre propre
protection
avons-nous pu d'ores et déjà recomplétez
nos stocks concernant ce matériel en
outre le budget consacré à la défense
solaire a toujours été un parent pauvre
des précédentes LPM le conflit en
Ukraine nous démontre à quel point la
défense solaire est essentielle pour la
protection du territoire national dans
ce contexte quel budget voulez-vous
consacrer monsieur le ministre dans la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
à cette question et quels sont vos
priorités d'investissement ce sens je
vous remercie
merci la parole est à Christophe Niger
que je félicite pour sa nomination donc
comme rapporteur de la mission
d'information dédiée au soutien
militaire français à l'Ukraine
militaire de plus soyons réalistes
certaines livraisons peuvent se faire
sans trop de conséquences je pense
notamment aux véhicules de l'avant
blindé allez va B dont le remplacement
est déjà acté via le programme scorpion
cependant pour les autres livraisons
comme les 18 Césars sur les 76 que de
détenaient notre armée de terre ou les
deux lance-roquettes unitaires sur les
13 en stock cette appui là est-il est
utile mais quid des conséquences sur
notre préparation opérationnelle par
ailleurs je sais que nous avons ici en
France un atout de taille ce sont nos
entreprises nos industriels toutes les
entreprises de la défense qui se
tiennent prêtes sont-elles en mesure de
soutenir le rythme pour reconstituer nos
stocks après livraison sur ce point je
tiens vous alerter les entreprises de
notre BITD font face à des obstacles
manque de manoeuvre réticence des
banques à financier à financer et
lourdeur des procédures imposées par le
règlement européen REACH que
proposez-vous pour elle notre industrie
doit avoir toutes les cartes en main si
nous voulons poursuivre de front ce
soutien indispensable à l'Ukraine est la
remise à niveau de nos armées merci la
parole est à Christian Gérard
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous vous remercions pour vos
propos éclairants sur le soutien à
l'Ukraine qui nous permet de saisir au
mieux le rôle de notre pays dans la
recherche de l'équilibre des puissances
en corrélation avec le soutien à
l'Ukraine les retours que nous avons du
conflit nous font observer des pertes
conséquentes en termes d'hommes les
armées régulières et professionnelles de
chaque camp soumise à forte attrition
ont été mises à rue des preuves et le
conflit tient beaucoup sur les réserves
sur la loi martiale et sur les
mobilisations partielles décrétées ma
question est de savoir comment faire
gagner nos réserves militaires en masse
en cas d’engagement de notre pays dans
un conflit de haute intensité et d'usure
prématurée de nos militaires
professionnels de nombreux sujets
d'inquiétudes demeurent car la formation
de réserviste opérationnelle ne se fait
pas dans un jour le CNU n'y semble pas
destiné et le dernier sondage réalisé
par galope en 2017 avait donné avait
donné seulement un taux de 29% de
réponses positives à la question de
savoir s'il est sonder était prêt à
aller se battre pour le pays ce qui en
dit long sur la force morale des
potentiels réserve du pays aussi à quel
à quel grain axe envisagez-vous pour
épaissir nos réserves en quantité et en
qualité je vous remercie merci enfin la
parole est à Vincent Bru
la porte matérielle de la France à
l'armée ukrainienne qui est tout à fait
légitime a suscité des interrogations
les biens prélevés dans les stocks de
nos armées ont questionné l'opinion sur
les risques que nous faisions
éventuellement encourir à notre défense
le cas du César que vous avez cité a été
cité le ministère s'est engagé à livrer
12 nouveaux Césars en plus des 18 qui
ont déjà été donnés l'inquiétude apporté
sur le fait de ponctionner nos stocks
qui étaient à 73 César avant février
2022 de fait Nexter s'est mobilisé pour
répondre à la demande de l'État pour le
compte de l'Ukraine et de recompléter
les stocks français ainsi pouvez-vous
nous dire si nos stocks sont aujourd'hui
revenus à leur niveau initial
le fait d'avoir dû prélever des Césars
dans nos stocks souligne aussi que les
industriels n'ont pas été en capacité de
répondre totalement à la demande je vous
demande donc si la relocalisation
annoncée d'une vingtaine d'industries de
la défense pourraient permettre
d'accélérer la production de nos
industriels je vous remercie merci pour
accélérer les choses je vous propose de
prendre les trois dernières questions
maintenant la parole est à Julien en
cool
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre dans le cadre du soutien à
l'Ukraine la France a été mobilisée avec
une prise en charge médicalisée de
blessés de guerre par des actions
conjoines du ministère des armées du
ministère des Affaires étrangères et du
ministère de la Santé alors que les deux
armées subissent en Ukraine un nombre
très important de blesser par plusieurs
dizaines de milliers cela doit nous
pousser à une réflexion sur notre propre
service de santé des armées on a vu au
cours du conflit ukrainien de très
nombreux blessés touchés en première
ligne assez loin des hôpitaux militaires
j'en déduis qu'avoir des capacités
opérationnelles importantes de Médecine
d'Urgence directement sur le front est
essentiel dans le cadre de la haute
intensité la formation au gestes de
secours de nos soldats notamment par les
modules de sauvetage au combat est aussi
un enjeu majeur
ainsi j'aimerais savoir si vous avez des
retours d'expérience pertinents
d'Ukraine à nous partager sur cette
prise en charge des blessés au front et
du soutien qu'elle nécessite quelle
conclusion en fait vous selon me paraît
un axe de réflexion important à avoir
pour adapter notre service de santé des
armées et éventuellement les techniques
de sauvetage cacarnes aux soldats au vu
d'une des nouveaux enjeux je vous
remercie merci la parole est à
Christophe Blanchet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais évoquer une arme de
guerre une munition mais qui n'a pas
besoin de poudre
je parlais de l'information
la gestion de l'information cette
information qui peut mobiliser comme un
peu démobiliser si on rappelle la vérité
le peuple russe aujourd'hui
subit une information qui n'est pas la
nôtre donc une désinformation et c'est
un angle d'attaque beaucoup de guerre se
gagne évidemment sur le terrain des
armes sur les la stratégie mais beaucoup
aussi sur la démobilisation du à une
réelle information et ce qu'on a une
réflexion là dessus pour pénétrer les
médias russe pénétrer le peuple russe je
ne sais pas de quelle manière mais cette
bataille de l'information pour
démobiliser le soutien
qu'ils peuvent apporter à leur président
est une vraie bataille si on veut
réussir à terme à revenir sur la base
des négociations pour la paix et enfin
on a gardé le meilleur pour la fin la
parole est à Jean-Pierre cuberte à fond
je vous remercie monsieur le président
des vice-présidents
monsieur le Président je suis navré de
ces interventions
c'est la dernière ce n'est pas une
question c'est une information je
voulais me réjouir et vous donner cette
information la Dordogne a appris avec
beaucoup de plaisir que on allait
relocaliser la fabrication de poudre à
Bergerac et je tenais à remercier le
ministre parce que c'est à son suite à
son intervention que la poudrerie de
Bergerac va relocaliser la fabrication
de pauvres qui avait été délocalisé en
Suède donc on ne peut que se féliciter
pour la Dordogne bien sûr en premier et
pour notre pays
merci chers collègues monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole merci
beaucoup je vais
effectivement attendu dans dans
l'hémicycle donc je vais être le plus
synthétique possible
service de santé des armées bah oui pour
ça le monsieur cubert taffon je le
remercie à mon tour d'avoir aussi porté
ce dossier dans son département et on a
une nombreuses réunions de travail en
amont vous en étiez et vous remercierez
aussi de par la même les acteurs
industriels mais aussi les élus locaux
évidemment qui ont qui ont œuvré parce
que la relocalisation ça veut dire aussi
un territoire disponible pour le faire
surtout sur des activités aussi
dangereuses à mon tour je vais avoir une
pensée particulière évidemment pour pour
la victime évidemment dans les villes
dans les usines externes que Bergerac
est connu une explosion importante il y
a maintenant plusieurs semaines donc je
veux dire tout ça demande aussi une
résilience territoriale et votre
département est le réseau d'élus qui
vous entourent en font preuve voilà je
voulais vraiment aussi le dire ici
Monsieur le Député sur service de santé
des armées bon plusieurs manières
d'aider
évidemment la prise en charge de blessés
dans des situations particulièrement
complexes et difficiles sur lequel
évidemment on apporte un concours au
moment où je vous parle c'est une
dizaine de blessés qui sont traités dans
les hôpitaux militaires français sur des
pathologies particulièrement lourdes
motrices essentiellement de
reconstruction qui sont derrière assez
assez mouvantes quand on les visite le
soutien médical à l'Ukraine il passe
aussi par la formation on parle de
formation sur plein de sujets mais il
faut aussi en parler évidemment ça
permet de parler aussi du retour
d'expérience cool sur on a déjà un bon
retour d'expérience et pour cause
barkhane et pour cause l'exposition
c'est une armée d'emploi avec
malheureusement des tuer des blessés et
donc on a déjà un retour d'expérience
important dont on arrive à faire
profiter aux Ukrainiens parmi les
formations le sujet sera pour le service
de santé des armées mais j'y reviendrai
dans le cadre de la prévention militaire
c'est la concomitance de plusieurs
crises en même temps dire que un
engagement majeur et un attentat de
masse dans lequel les hôpitaux de Beja
et persil à Paris sont publicité et une
pandémie type covid et si vous avez
plusieurs plusieurs enjeux ou crise en
même temps la concomitance des crises
est un des sujets qui me préoccupent
pour le service de santé des armées
après quand on prend les défis
individuellement il y a un engagement du
SSA qui est absolument remarquable et
pour le coup les choses sont bien tenues
enfin dans les sessions j'en parle
jamais mais on a évidemment
pratiquement céder pour un demi million
d'euros de matériel de soins pour les
combattants Ukrainiens parce
qu'évidemment là aussi il y a pas de il
y a pas de santé en tout cas il y a pas
de soin de combat sur un certain nombre
d'équipements d'équipements spécifiques
sur la défense sol R
pour le coup c'est un des enjeux
importants pour le député Ardoin de la
future le programmation militaire sera
pratiquement 5 milliards d'euros en la
matière oui les décisions de
recomplètement sont déjà en cours j'ai
parlé des crottes il va sans dire que
les décisions sur les VL micas sont en
train d'être prises en tout cas moi je
les ai validés politiquement après un
certain nombre de comités ministériel
d'investissement vont se tenir et vous
retrouverez tout ça dans les différentes
programmations budgétaires que nous se
mettrons au Parlement cela va sans dire
monsieur le Président neglen bravo pour
votre mission elle est importante alors
vous vous l'avez un peu problématisé de
manière globale avec les différents
enjeux qu'il faudra traiter moi
évidemment je fais l'ensemble du
ministère et à la disposition de la
mission pour répondre et approfondir
peut-être aussi un certain nombre de
points je pense qu'il y a tout un enjeu
lié à l'économie de guerre dans ce que
vous avez dit c'est à dire en clair
quelle est la visibilité que l'on donne
aux entreprises pour relever le défi dès
lors que notre BTD est branché
complètement à notre l'armée il faut
donc que la béité des suivent je crois
qu'on n'a pas le choix notre modèle
français depuis les années 60 il repose
là-dessus le problème c'est
qu'évidemment 20 ans de lutte contre le
terrorisme fait qu'on a utilisé plus ou
moins les mêmes armements à chaque fois
et là tout d'un coup un engagement
majeur les sessions à l'Ukraine mais pas
que peuvent aussi donner une réflexion
nouvelle sur la trission sur évidemment
le ratio entre la rusticité et la
technologie à soutenabilité économique
de cette affaire-là bon et puis le
risque aussi que l'entreprise doit
prendre et là je crois que c'est aussi
un sujet clé parce que c'est du c'est
aussi de la visibilité que l'État doit à
l'entreprise l'accompagnement à l'export
parce que on le dit pas assez mais enfin
c'est parce qu'elle l'export d'armement
que notre modèle est équilibré sinon on
serait condamné depuis bien longtemps à
acheter à Pékin Washington ou Moscou en
fonction des affinités des uns des
autres donc je crois que là aussi qu'on
se fasse preuve de pédagogie
collectivement sur les conditions
justement de cette autonomie stratégique
donc là il y a tout un sujet que
l'Ukraine révèle et je pense le
Président vous vous rendrez compte est
aussi que le covid soulevé sur les
chaînes logistiques sur les supply
chaînes sur la gestion des stocks
stratégiques et c'est bien souvent
d'ailleurs le covid qui a donné quelques
frayeurs sur des hpinements d'un certain
nombre de matières premières qui me
donnent donc aujourd'hui la l'occasion
de prendre des décisions de
relocalisation ce qui permet de répondre
aussi à ce qui a été dit parce que c'est
pas qu'une affaire de guerre c'est tout
simplement aussi une affaire de
sécurisation des chaînes logistiques
donc ça l'enjeu il est majeur sur les
Césars je l'indiqué tout à l'heure ça va
être un bon exemple de ce qui fonctionne
44 mois pour construire un César on est
en train de tomber à 18 mois ce
spectaculaire de la part d'un externe il
faut rendre hommage aux équipes parce
que le vent dans du le message ce qui va
nous permettre quand même entre novembre
de cette année et mars de 2024 de voir
30 nouveaux Césars livrés l'armée
française donc là vous voyez on commence
ça y est dans la mécanique sauf que ce
qui est vrai pour un canon César sera
peut-être d'une autre nature pour un
missile une munition complexe sera
encore d'une autre nature pour les
munitions tout court donc là je pense
qu'après par typologie d'armement il
faudra évidemment aussi regarder comment
cette affaire cette affaire fonction en
tout cas une fois plus moi je suis à
votre à votre disposition pour moi c'est
clé c'est clé aussi pour la réussite de
notre stratégie à l'export vous aurez de
plus en plus des clients à l'exportation
qui feront de la réactivité et de la
maîtrise et du calendrier et du prix une
des conditions d'achat et d'ailleurs
quand tout le monde découvre mais
d'accord mais pourquoi les Polonais
achètent en Corée du Sud et achètent pas
américain bah tout simplement parce que
même l'industrie américaine livre trop
lentement voilà donc là je pense qu'il y
a une prise de conscience aussi en
termes de de compétitivité française
avec tout ce que ça veut dire aussi pour
les emplois locaux qui vont avec donc là
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir mais ce sont
413 milliards d'euros une LPM ambitieuse
tout ça c'est très bien mais la réalité
c'est que il y a pas il y aura pas de
LPM réussi si on n'a pas une industrie
qui bouge en même temps que les armées
ça je et j'aurais besoin de vous parce
que ça aussi un combat culturel que les
PME ne sont pas les grandes entreprises
que les grandes entreprises qui sont les
anciens arsenaux de l'État ne sont pas
les entreprises qui ont toujours été
sous capitaux privés en termes de
culture qu'il y a des enjeux aussi sur
le financement j'ai aujourd'hui la
plupart des PME du monde de l'armement
ont du mal aussi à lever un certain
nombre d'emprunts bancaires voilà parce
que parce que l'armement c'est ça pardon
de le dire avec mes mots comme cela je
suis désolé au bout d'un moment
j'appelle aussi à ce que la finance soit
patriotique transition écologique c'est
fondamentale mais enfin l'autonomie
stratégique française pour se défendre
et défendre nos valeurs ça allait tout
autant donc ça je pense que là il y a un
enjeu important et moi évidemment je
serai votre complice si vous l'acceptez
pour réussir cette mission parce que je
pense que c'est aussi la faire du
Parlement et c'est pas que l'affaire des
militaires ou la DGA etc on a besoin de
tout s'y mettre sur la réserve on y
reviendra monsieur le député mais c'est
clé c'est que les pas que pour la haute
intensité c'est que pour plein de sujets
je reviens au covid je reviens en crise
climatique dans les territoires
d'outre-mer sur lequel se sont souvent
les armées qui sont première à marcher
pour venir donner des solutions même pas
un outre-mer on l'a vu que les incendies
très graves sur le dans l'Hexagone l'été
dernier donc il est clair que là la
professionnalisation des réserves si
j'ose dire une évolution de la doctrine
d'un point de nos réserves est
absolument clé elle n'est pas sans lien
avec avec le SMU interne tout simplement
parce que plus on éveille à l'engagement
plus on a envie d'être utile pour son
pays c'est pas forcément la réserve
militaire ça peut être la réserve
sanitaire ça peut être la réserve de sa
vie civique et plusieurs manières après
de le faire vivre mais je pense que ça
évidemment c'est un sujet clé et il
faudra que que l'on avance là-dessus
informations bon ça c'est un sujet dont
je pense que le député le Parlement doit
s'en emparer parce que de toutes les
évidences une démocratie ne pourra pas
traiter ce sujet avec la même doctrine
qu'un pays autoritaire non mais
j'enfonce une énorme porte ouverte et je
suis frappé d'ailleurs que le sujet ne
soit pas plus mis en avant comme cela
c'est on a un droit de la presse
la communication
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose que
la presse donc l'information c'est donc
aussi la stratégie de désinformation
est-ce qu'une démocratie peut et doit
faire la même chose qu'un pays
autoritaire la réponse est non déjà bon
donc là il y a aussi un enjeu
intéressant pour un parlement me
semble-t-il que de s'emparer aussi de
cette question sachant qu'après comme
pour tous les sujets il y a des sujets
qui sont plus ou moins discrets plus ou
moins secrets plus ou moins de temps
destin que l'on subit que se protéger ce
n'est pas la se protéger d'une campagne
des informations ce n'est pas la même
chose que éventuellement la menée
soi-même enfin mais je parle pas comme
ministre pour la France je raisonne de
manière globale et je vous le disais ce
sont des sujets qui sont pas
suffisamment traités dans les enceintes
européennes ou même l'enceinte de l'OTAN
et ce sont mon avis des beaux sujets
pour pour cette législature
merci Monsieur alors toute dernière
question de notre collègue Emmanuel
Fernandez
voilà si vous l'avez dit moi je veux en
toute humilité je peux pas revendiquer
ça mais je vous prie de m'excuser
d'avoir été absent dans l'ordre de
passage petit problème de coordination
avec l'hémicycle mais ça fait du sport
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre il y a quelques jours le
directeur général de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique
Rafael grossi alerté une fois de plus la
communauté internationale après une
frappe russe à proximité de la centrale
nucléaire ukrainienne de zapporigia dont
le fonctionnement ne tient plus
aujourd'hui qu'aux générateur de secours
à chaque fois dit-il à chaque fois on
joue avec le feu et si nous permettons à
cette situation de se prolonger un jour
notre chance va tourner
avertissait-il insistant pour que les
nations s'engagent à protéger la
sécurité du site qui selon lui ne peut
passer que par la création d'une zone
spéciale permettez-moi ici une petite
parenthèse pour rappeler que dès le 4
mars 2022 un certain Jean-Luc Mélenchon
se prononçait pour que la France demande
à l'ONU que soit fixé une zone tampon
contre les combats autour de la centrale
zone tenue par une force d'interposition
sous l'égide des Nations Unies or voilà
maintenant plusieurs mois que le chef de
la IEA mène de très difficile
consultation avec l'Ukraine et la Russie
visant à aboutir à la mise en place
d'une telle d'une telle zone de
protection
asaporigia pour atteindre cet objectif
certes désormais très éloigné
effectivement désormais très éloigné
mais pourtant tellement indispensable
absolument indispensable il somme le
directeur de l'IA il somme la communauté
internationale qu'il qualifie de passive
sur le sujet assez impliqué avec ardeur
alors malgré le fait qu'un temps
précieux ait été perdu pouvez-vous
monsieur le ministre nous indiquer les
mesures qui sont prises par le
gouvernement pour que la France
malheureusement restait passive en mars
2022 ne puisse plus être qualifié comme
tel par celui dont la mission est de
mettre sous contrôle le risque immense
que représente la centrale de zapporja
dans le conflit je vous remercie
vous avez tort de politiser la question
parce que précisément
s'il y a bien un pays qui soutient les
efforts monsieur grossit depuis le début
c'est bien la République française je
pense que là dessus on devrait tous se
retrouver
là où la capitale par laquelle monsieur
grossi est passé justement avant de
déclencher les missions respectivement à
Moscou et à Kiev et avant de se rendre à
saporica c'est à Paris je peux en parler
j'étais là les efforts diplomatiques que
le Président de la République a pu mener
avec les deux parties je peux en
témoigner j'étais là quels sont les
circonstances dans lesquelles je me suis
shoegout ministre de la défense de la
Fédération de Russie c'est justement sur
le dossier de zaborita y compris lorsque
on a eu des informations qui étaient
particulièrement difficiles à comprendre
et sur lequel nous sommes montés au
créneau pour permettre à la Ia de mener
de mener sa mission bon la difficulté il
faut le rappeler déjà c'est que si les
Russes n'occupaient pas la centrale il y
aurait pas de difficulté ça va mieux en
disant que évidemment la militarisation
de ce site nucléaire civil fait partie
cette ibérité dont on ne veut pas dans
ce conflit parce que là pour le coup on
est sur une prise en otage d'un objet
nucléaire civil à des fins militaires
d'ailleurs objectifivement nous on
soutient la IEA pour aller au-delà même
de la question des aporis de chat parce
que on n'est pas à l'abri demain qu'un
missile tombe sur un ensemble de
réacteurs d'une autre centrale du pays
comme vous le savez l'Ukraine comporte
un parc nucléaire important qu'au de la
même des actions militaires sur la
centrale il y a aussi des enjeux de
sûreté qui nous préoccupent tout
simplement parce que beaucoup de
personnels d'exploitation et de
maintenance de la centrale pour des
raisons qu'on peut comprendre
humainement ont quitté la centrale
c'est-à-dire tous les process habituels
et classiques de la vie normale du
centre du centre nucléaire de saporica
évidemment on se retrouve dans une autre
logique sur laquelle la ioa évidemment
surveille de près les choses qui est des
enjeux évidemment de production
d'électricité pour permettre à tous les
systèmes de refroidissement etc de la
centrale bon donc tout ça est largement
documenté la réalité c'est que c'est
même plutôt de Paris qui prend le lead
sur cette affaire parce que évidemment
notre proximité avec l'Ukraine fait
aussi que pour des raisons qui tient la
sécurité de nos populations les
populations européennes on se sent
évidemment mobilisés et puis et puis on
ne veut pas
vraiment je pense que faut laisser la
lieux à travailler et à chaque fois que
Monsieur grossit demande quelque chose
au présent de la République ou à Madame
Colonna ou à moi-même on s'efforce de le
faire voilà après je dis pas tout mais
en tout cas sachez qu'on est mobilisé
sur le sujet sont personne n'a intérêt à
avoir un problème sur saporicha personne
j'enfonce une porte ouverte mais ça va
mieux là aussi en 10 ans merci monsieur
le ministre pour votre disponibilité la
clarté de vos propos que je crois chacun
ici apprécier au-delà de nos différentes
sensibilités politiques mes chers
collègues prochaines audition mercredi
prochain à 9 heures
merci